This episode is brought to you by Lloyd's business and commercial banking. One of the great things about finance is that it may result in you having to pay tax. And this was a constant grumble in Anglo-Saxon England, which was the most heavily taxed country in the whole of Christendom. And just when the Anglo-Saxons thought it couldn't get any worse, they got conquered by King Canute. And Canute imposed a tax rate that was effectively 100%. Yeah, well, that was one very big change, Tom, but another tax change is upon us. And this is the advent of making tax digital for income tax. And if you're at all concerned about it, this is where Lloyd's come in, because they're here to help make that change much simpler for you with a useful HMRC-recognised accounting tool that will help you stay in line with all the making tax digital requirements. And the brilliant thing about this is that it is free for Lloyd's business account customers. So when it is time to digitise your income tax, you can bank on Lloyd's. Search Lloyd's business accounts to find out more.
本期节目由劳埃德银行（Lloyd's）商业与企业银行赞助播出。金融的一大妙处在于，它可能会让你不得不缴税。这在盎格鲁-撒克逊时期的英格兰是一个永恒的抱怨，当时它是整个基督教世界中税负最重的国家。而就在盎格鲁-撒克逊人以为情况不会再糟的时候，他们被克努特大帝征服了。克努特征收的税率实际上达到了100%。是的，那确实是一个巨大的变化，汤姆，但现在我们又面临着另一项税务变革。这就是“所得税数字化”（Making Tax Digital）的到来。如果你对此有任何顾虑，劳埃德银行可以为你提供帮助，他们提供了一款实用的、经英国税务海关总署（HMRC）认可的会计工具，旨在帮助你更轻松地应对这一变革，确保你符合“所得税数字化”的所有要求。最棒的是，这项服务对劳埃德银行的商业账户客户是免费的。因此，当需要将你的所得税数字化时，你可以信赖劳埃德银行。搜索“劳埃德商业账户”了解更多信息。
Hello everybody. So those were the two opening verse. of the South African National Anthem. Unkosi Sikailili Africa, which were sung by the Imelungi Kantu Choral Society at the Rugby World Cup Final of 1995. So I remember very vividly watching that final, a great match, incredibly tense, very exciting. So the match was held in Johannesburg at Ellis Park,
大家好。刚才那是南非国歌的前两段，《上帝保佑非洲》（Nkosi Sikelel' iAfrika），由伊梅伦吉·坎图合唱团（Imelungi Kantu Choral Society）在1995年橄榄球世界杯决赛上演唱。我清楚地记得观看那场决赛的情景，那是一场伟大的比赛，极其紧张，非常令人兴奋。比赛在约翰内斯堡的埃利斯公园球场举行，
the totemic stadium of the Springboks, South Africa, and they were playing the All Blacks, or New Zealand. Now, the All Blacks were overwhelming favourites. They were and are the dominant national team in any sport, not just rugby. The All Blacks had steamroll of their way through the tournament. They kicked off, of course, with the hacker, with their Maori dance, which intimidates their opponents. They had in Jonah Lumu, the star of the tournament, probably the most intimidating rugby player compared to his peers who has ever existed. Lomby, this absolute man-mountain.
那是南非跳羚队（Springboks）的图腾式球场，他们当时对阵的是全黑队（All Blacks），也就是新西兰队。当时，全黑队是压倒性的热门。他们不仅在橄榄球领域，在任何体育项目中都是占据统治地位的国家队。全黑队一路势如破竹地杀入决赛。当然，他们以哈卡舞（Haka）开场，那是他们的毛利战舞，用来震慑对手。他们拥有乔纳·洛穆（Jonah Lumu），他是那届比赛的明星，可能是橄榄球历史上与其同辈球员相比最具威慑力的球员。洛穆，这座绝对的人形大山。
So anyone who remembers the all-blacks playing England in the semi-final will remember him absolutely crunching his way through the England defence to score try after try, crushing the Underwood Brothers underfoot. And he scored four tries, and he's this massive, massive presence, isn't he, Tom, in the tunnel? As the two teams are waiting to go onto the pitch, and basically the eyes of the sporting world are not on the springbox, even though they're the hosts, they're on the All-Backs, and everybody expects the All-Blacks to win. Yes, and just to explain for people who have no idea about rugby or what it involves, I will quote from John Carlin, who wrote an entire book Playing the Enemy about this 1995 final. He describes rugby as being like a giant chess match played at speed with great violence. And the reason that Lomu is widely regarded as the greatest rugby player of all time is that he's not only huge, he's also very, very fast. And so you combine those and it makes him an absolutely terrifying prospect.
所以，任何记得全黑队在半决赛中对阵英格兰队的人，都会记得他如何彻底碾压英格兰队的防线，一次又一次地达阵得分，将安德伍德兄弟踩在脚下。他一共达阵四次，他是一个如此庞大、如此具有压迫感的存在，对吧，汤姆？在球员通道里，当两队等待入场时，基本上全世界体育迷的目光都不在跳羚队身上，尽管他们是东道主，而是在全黑队身上，每个人都期待全黑队获胜。是的，为了向那些完全不懂橄榄球或其规则的人解释一下，我引用约翰·卡林（John Carlin）的话，他写了一整本关于这场1995年决赛的书《与敌共舞》（Playing the Enemy）。他将橄榄球描述为一场在高速和剧烈对抗中进行的巨型国际象棋比赛。洛穆被广泛认为是史上最伟大的橄榄球运动员，原因不仅在于他体型巨大，还在于他速度极快。将这两者结合起来，使他成为一个绝对令人恐惧的对手。
So, Dominic, as you said, when they're waiting to go out in the tunnel before the match starts, the South Africans, the Springboks cannot take their eyes off him. And to quote Joel Stransky, who was the Springbok fly half, which for American listeners is kind of vaguely the quarterback, would that be? Yeah, the fly half controls the game. Yeah. Basically, they did take the pace of the game. Stransky said, you know, he couldn't take his eyes off Lomu.
所以，多米尼克，正如你所说，当他们在比赛开始前在通道里等待出场时，南非跳羚队的球员们无法将目光从他身上移开。引用乔尔·斯特兰斯基（Joel Stransky）的话，他是跳羚队的传接锋（fly half），对于美国听众来说，这大概相当于四分卫，是吗？是的，传接锋控制着比赛。是的。基本上，他们掌控着比赛的节奏。斯特兰斯基说，你知道，他无法将目光从洛穆身上移开。
He looked like a mountain, one that we had to climb. And in the event, Dominic, South Africa, did climb that mountain. They did. Because the 1995 Rugby World Cup final turns out to be one of the great sporting upsets of all time. And the Sprinbox win in extra time by the skin of their teeth. And it's Stransky who scores all their points. Very unusual, I gather, for rugby.
他看起来像一座山，一座我们必须翻越的山。而最终，多米尼克，南非确实翻越了那座山。他们做到了。因为1995年橄榄球世界杯决赛成为了体育史上最伟大的冷门之一。跳羚队在加时赛中以微弱优势获胜。而斯特兰斯基包办了他们所有的得分。据我所知，这在橄榄球比赛中非常罕见。
This doesn't often happen. And the measure of Stransky's impact is that he gets to be played by Clint Eastwood's son's Scott in this film that was made in 2008 Invictus by Clint Eastwood himself. So listeners by this point may be wondering two things. Firstly, what on earth is Clint Eastwood doing making a film about a rugby match? Doesn't seem an obvious kind of thing for him to be doing. And secondly, why is a series that is marking the Football World Cup going on about a World Cup in a completely different sport. And the reason for this is that the 1995 Rugby World Cup
这种情况并不常见。斯特兰斯基的影响力之大，以至于在2008年由克林特·伊斯特伍德亲自执导的电影《成事在人》（Invictus）中，他由伊斯特伍德的儿子斯科特饰演。所以听众们此时可能会有两个疑问。首先，克林特·伊斯特伍德为什么要拍一部关于橄榄球比赛的电影？这看起来不像他会做的事情。其次，为什么一个纪念足球世界杯的系列节目要谈论一项完全不同运动的世界杯？原因在于1995年橄榄球世界杯
final was historic for reasons that completely transcended sport. And the singing of the national anthem, the South African National Anthem, by the Springboks at the start of this Rugby World Cup final is a crucial, crucial part of what makes the match historic. So before we go into the details of the anthem and why it matters so much to this extraordinary match, first of all, just to explain the significance of rugby in South Africa, it is introduced, obviously, by the British who colonise South Africa. But it evolves to become preeminently the sport of another white people in South Africa. And these are the Afrikaners, a people who over the course of the 20th century had transformed their country into a pariah state cut off from the rest of the world by a whole
决赛的历史意义完全超越了体育本身。跳羚队在决赛开始时演唱南非国歌，是这场比赛具有历史意义的关键所在。因此，在我们深入探讨国歌及其对这场非凡比赛的重要性之前，首先要解释一下橄榄球在南非的意义。它显然是由殖民南非的英国人引入的。但它逐渐演变成南非白人——阿非利卡人（Afrikaners）——的首要运动。阿非利卡人在20世纪将他们的国家变成了一个被世界孤立的贱民国家，受到了一系列
kind of array of business boycotts, cultural boycotts, international boycotts and sporting boycotts. And the sporting boycots matter enormously because rugby is one of the absolute symbols of Afrikanerdom and of Afrikaner identity. I mean, sport generally, but rugby in particular. So what had the Afrikaners done? Who are they? Why have they become so globally notorious? Why does no one want to play them at rugby or eat their oranges or whatever?
商业抵制、文化抵制、国际抵制和体育抵制的封锁。体育抵制的影响巨大，因为橄榄球是阿非利卡人精神和身份的绝对象征。我是说体育运动总体上如此，但橄榄球尤甚。那么阿非利卡人做了什么？他们是谁？为什么他们变得如此臭名昭著？为什么没人想和他们打橄榄球，或者吃他们的橙子之类的东西？
So listeners who feel that we haven't had nearly enough Dutch history on this series so far will be delighted to learn that the Afrikaners were originally Dutch Calvinists, plus a few Huguenots from France, so Protestants from France. Calvin always shows up at World Cups on the rest of history, doesn't he? It always does. In the 17th century, the Dutch and French Protestants had begun settling the Cape, so the southernmost point of Africa. But they didn't view themselves as colonists so much as a chosen people who had been brought into a promised land. So people will remember from the episode we did on the Dutch Republic that this was a crucial part of how the Dutch rebels saw themselves as a chosen people on the model of the Israelites who were led out of Egypt by Moses.
所以那些觉得我们在这个系列节目中荷兰历史讲得不够多的听众会很高兴地了解到，阿非利卡人最初是荷兰加尔文教徒，外加一些来自法国的胡格诺派教徒，也就是法国的新教徒。加尔文总是出现在历史系列的各个节点，不是吗？确实如此。在17世纪，荷兰和法国的新教徒开始在好望角定居，也就是非洲的最南端。但他们并不认为自己是殖民者，而更像是被带入应许之地的“选民”。所以人们会记得我们在荷兰共和国那期节目中提到的，这是荷兰叛军如何将自己视为摩西带领出埃及的以色列人模式的“选民”的关键部分。
And of course, just as the Israelites end up being led into Canaan and conquering the Canaanites and taking it and turning it into Israel, so do the Afrikaners see Africa in a similar manner. It is a land that has been given to them by God and the fact that there are people already living there. Well, that's all part of God's plan. Yeah. And they went on a great trek, didn't they, rather like Exodus, so the Vortrek. And the trek becomes part of their mythology, the trek to the promised land. Well, they do this not because they're getting away from black Africans, but because they're getting away from the second wave of white colonial invaders who are, of course, the British. And they end up absorbing the whole of South Africa, the Afrikaners included into their empire, even though the Afrikaners, as you say, they go deep into the interior. The British follow them and they find that there are kind of diamonds and things. So, obviously, the British aren't going to let the Afrikaners have them. So the Afrikaners find themselves of the British Empire, they don't like it. They fight a war, another name by which they're known
当然，正如以色列人最终被引导进入迦南，征服迦南人并将其变成以色列一样，阿非利卡人也以类似的方式看待非洲。这是一片上帝赐予他们的土地，而那里已经有人居住的事实，嗯，那都是上帝计划的一部分。是的。他们进行了大迁徙，不是吗？就像《出埃及记》一样，即“大迁徙”（Great Trek）。这次迁徙成为了他们神话的一部分，通往应许之地的迁徙。嗯，他们这样做不是为了逃离黑人非洲人，而是为了逃离第二波白人殖民入侵者，也就是英国人。他们最终将整个南非，包括阿非利卡人，都纳入了他们的帝国，尽管阿非利卡人正如你所说，深入了内陆。英国人跟随他们，发现那里有钻石之类的东西。所以，显然英国人不会让阿非利卡人拥有这些。因此，阿非利卡人发现自己处于大英帝国的统治之下，他们不喜欢这样。他们打了一场战争，他们被称为
is the Burrs, so this is what the Burr Wars are all about. But all the while, conservative Afrikaners, they never doubt that God's plan is still working itself out, that they are bound by a covenant to God, that the British Empire will end up collapsing. And so the Afrikaners by their time, and sure enough, in due course by 1948, the sun is setting on the British Empire, and a government dominated by these Afrikaner conservatives gets elected to power. And the voters at this point are only white. So black Africans do not have the vote. And this government that gets elected in 1948, its stated ambition is to solidify the
布尔人（Boers），这就是布尔战争的由来。但与此同时，保守的阿非利卡人从未怀疑上帝的计划仍在运作，他们与上帝立有盟约，大英帝国最终会崩溃。因此，阿非利卡人在等待时机，果然，到1948年，大英帝国的太阳正在落下，一个由这些阿非利卡保守派主导的政府当选上台。当时的选民只有白人。所以黑人非洲人没有投票权。而这个在1948年当选的政府，其既定目标是将
Afrikaners sense of themselves as a chosen people into an entire political program. And what does this mean in practice? It means instituting a policy of what they call set. which in Afrikaans is apartheid. And so white rule is enshrined as the expression of God's will. The Afrikaners obviously are not instituting apartheid because they think it's wicked or evil. They think that it is expressive of God's purpose. However, the practical consequences of this is to enshrine racial segregation as the animating principle of the entire South African state. So whether it is buying a house or falling in love or sitting or not sitting on a bench in a park or getting
阿非利卡人作为“选民”的自我意识固化为一个完整的政治纲领。这在实践中意味着什么？这意味着实施他们所谓的“种族隔离”（apartheid）。因此，白人统治被奉为上帝意志的体现。阿非利卡人显然不是因为认为种族隔离是邪恶的才实施它的。他们认为这是上帝旨意的表达。然而，其实际后果是将种族隔离确立为整个南非国家的驱动原则。无论是买房、坠入爱河、坐在公园长椅上，还是接受
an education. So pretty much every aspect of daily life in South Africa, the opportunities that you have are dependent on the colour of your skin. It is racist to the very kind of depths of its marrow. Yeah. And to give people a sense, by the way, the black population of South Africa in this point, the 1940s, is about two-thirds. The white population is about a fifth. Then there's what's called a coloured population, which was mixed race, and labourers from India who have been brought in. So basically, you've got 20% of the population
教育。所以南非日常生活的几乎每一个方面，你所拥有的机会都取决于你的肤色。这是一种深入骨髓的种族主义。是的。顺便给听众一个概念，当时（20世纪40年代）南非的黑人人口约占三分之二。白人人口约占五分之一。然后是所谓的“有色人种”，即混血儿，以及从印度带来的劳工。所以基本上，你有20%的人口
who are governing the lives of the other 80%. Yes, and the 20% who are white are enshrined as the masters, and the black population in particular are essentially a kind of a servant class, a helot class. Yes. And they are denied educational opportunities that would enable them to combat this. This is all part of the kind of the plan. And the role that rugby plays in this, so John Carlin in his book, points out that rugby becomes the Africana sport par excellence.
在统治其他80%人的生活。是的，20%的白人被奉为主人，而黑人人口尤其是被视为一种仆人阶级，一种奴隶阶级。是的。他们被剥夺了使他们能够反抗这种制度的教育机会。这都是计划的一部分。而橄榄球在其中扮演的角色，约翰·卡林在他的书中指出，橄榄球成为了阿非利卡人卓越的运动。
And it serves as a perfect metaphor for the brutality that is inherent in apartheid. So to quote him, successive South African national teams had built up a reputation during the 20th century as the most bruisingly physical rugby players in the world. world. So in other words, they essentially kind of trample down anyone in their path and shoulder them out of the way. I mean, even now, they're the most physical of all teams, by far. And you can see why, therefore, to black South Africans, rugby comes to seem symbolic of apartheid and the kind of the very distinctive green jersey of the spring box, the South African national team. It becomes one of the defining emblems of the apartheid system that the black South Africans are kind of groaning under.
它成为了种族隔离制度中固有的残酷性的完美隐喻。引用他的话，在20世纪，历届南非国家队都以世界上最具身体对抗性的橄榄球运动员而闻名。换句话说，他们基本上会践踏路径上的任何人，并将他们撞开。即使在今天，他们也是所有球队中身体对抗最强的，遥遥领先。因此你可以看出，为什么对于南非黑人来说，橄榄球成为了种族隔离的象征，而跳羚队那件非常独特的绿色球衣，成为了南非黑人在种族隔离制度下呻吟的标志性符号之一。
Yeah. And this is why anti-apartheid campaigners who are emerging over the course of the 50s, 60s, 70s into the 80s, are very, very keen to see the South Africa banned from all international sport, but particularly from rugby, because they know, as you kind of implied, that is the ban that will hurt and upset the Afrikaners the most. And it's not until 1981 that a full boycott of the spring box is successfully instituted. But it is brought in. And this means that in, In 1987, when the first Rugby World Cup is held in Australia and New Zealand, South Africa are not invited. They are not present. So too in 1991, when the Second World Cup is held in England, because at that point, apartheid is still holding. But then in 1995, South Africa are not just participants, but the hosts. So obviously, something very dramatic has happened.
是的。这就是为什么在50、60、70年代一直到80年代涌现的反种族隔离运动者，非常非常渴望看到南非被禁止参加所有国际体育赛事，尤其是橄榄球，因为他们知道，正如你所暗示的那样，那是会让阿非利卡人最痛苦、最难受的禁令。直到1981年，对跳羚队的全面抵制才成功实施。但它确实被执行了。这意味着在1987年，当第一届橄榄球世界杯在澳大利亚和新西兰举行时，南非没有被邀请。他们没有出席。1991年第二届世界杯在英格兰举行时也是如此，因为那时种族隔离制度依然存在。但到了1995年，南非不仅是参赛者，还是东道主。所以显然，发生了非常戏剧性的事情。
Some radical change in the makeup of the South African government and constitution. has occurred. And basically, that change has been a process beginning in 1990 of the dismantling of the apartheid regime and a consigning of the entire doctrine of white supremacy to the ideological scrap heap. And it's a massive, massive story. You and I lived through it. Yeah, huge. But people who haven't may be startled to learn that there was a government so profoundly racist and now it's kind of completely collapsed. And numerous factors contribute to the process of this collapse, the collapse of apartheid. So chiefly, there come to be massive black resistance movements.
南非政府和宪法的构成发生了根本性的变化。基本上，这种变化是一个从1990年开始的过程，即拆除种族隔离政权，并将整个白人至上主义学说扔进意识形态的垃圾堆。这是一个非常非常宏大的故事。你和我亲历了它。是的，非常宏大。但没有经历过的人可能会惊讶地发现，曾经有一个如此深刻的种族主义政府，而现在它已经彻底崩溃了。许多因素促成了这一崩溃过程，即种族隔离的崩溃。主要是，出现了大规模的黑人抵抗运动。
There are campaigns of mass civil disobedience. And by the late 1980s, going into the 1990s, this essentially is making South Africa pretty ungovernable. We've talked about the sporting boycotts, but I mean, it's the, I think the economic sanctions kind of cripple the South Africa. African economy, not immediately, but it's a kind of slowly deflating puncture. South African business classes can feel the life kind of whistling out of the economy. Yeah.
有大规模的公民不服从运动。到了80年代末，进入90年代，这基本上使南非变得几乎无法治理。我们谈到了体育抵制，但我认为经济制裁实际上瘫痪了南非经济，不是立即生效，但它像是一个缓慢放气的轮胎。南非商界阶层能感觉到生命力正从经济中流失。是的。
And I think the cultural sanctions actually are massively important as well because they create this sense of isolation, a sense that the rest of the world hates you. Remember that song in the, um, a hysterical song in the 1980s? I've never met a nice South African. Yeah. I mean, there was a sense that South Africa, I think, was having been a sort of promised land for emigrants in their white imagination in the 20th century. Mrs. Thatcher's son, Tony Gregg, a host of people.
我认为文化制裁也非常重要，因为它们创造了一种孤立感，一种全世界都讨厌你的感觉。还记得80年代那首歇斯底里的歌吗？《我从未见过一个好南非人》（I've never met a nice South African）。是的。我的意思是，有一种感觉，南非在20世纪白人的想象中曾经是移民的应许之地。撒切尔夫人的儿子、托尼·格雷格，还有许多人。
It becomes such a pariah that that cannot help but have a corrosive effect on Afriana's sense of self-worth, which goes to your next point, Tom, which is about their... They lose self-confidence. Yeah, exactly. And they lose moral self-confidence. And I wrote about this in Dominion. I was amazed the degree to which kind of theological anxieties about whether apartheid was part of God's plan actually played a crucial role in deflating the self-confidence of the
它变成了一个如此受排斥的国家，这不可避免地对阿非利卡人的自我价值感产生了腐蚀作用，这引出了你的下一个观点，汤姆，关于他们的……他们失去了自信。是的，正是如此。他们失去了道德自信。我在《多米尼恩》（Dominion）中写过这一点，我惊讶地发现，关于种族隔离是否是上帝计划一部分的神学焦虑，实际上在削弱种族隔离政权的自信方面发挥了关键作用，
apartheid regime because so many leading members of the South African government were very devout Christians. And they started to worry that actually apartheid was, as the rest of the world was saying, a kind of mortal sin. You know, basically they, it all kind of, you know, theologically deflated as well as economically and deflated in terms of law and order. But even so, they still might have decided to hold on. I mean, they're a massive minority. They have been suppressing the black majority for decades and decades and decades. They must be nervous about what their fate might be if they give up power.
因为南非政府的许多领导成员都是非常虔诚的基督徒。他们开始担心，实际上种族隔离正如世界其他地方所说的那样，是一种“弥天大罪”。你知道，基本上，他们在神学上、经济上以及法律和秩序方面都崩溃了。但即便如此，他们可能还是决定坚持下去。我的意思是，他们是一个庞大的少数群体。他们几十年来一直在压迫黑人多数派。如果他们放弃权力，他们肯定会担心自己的命运。
And so I think that even with everything that is going wrong for them, they might still have tried to maintain apartheid. Had it not been for the fact that there existed a black leader with whom the leaders of the apartheidians of the apartheidate, Partite regime could contemplate doing business. And this black leader is, of course, one of the most famous political figures of the late 20th century, and that is Nelson Mandela. By far the most formidable, the most celebrated of all the revolutionaries that the campaign against apartheid throws up in South Africa, a member of an OSA-speaking royal family. He becomes the deputy president of the African National Congress and the African National Congress, the ANC, is the leading organization in the struggle against the white rule, and Mandela founds the spear of the nation, which is in effect the armed wing of the ANC.
所以我认为，即使一切都在恶化，他们可能还是会试图维持种族隔离。如果不是因为存在一位黑人领袖，而种族隔离政权的领导人可以考虑与他进行谈判。这位黑人领袖当然是20世纪末最著名的政治人物之一，那就是纳尔逊·曼德拉。他是南非反种族隔离运动中涌现出的最强大、最受赞誉的革命者，出身于一个讲科萨语的皇室家族。他成为非洲人国民大会（ANC）的副主席，而非洲人国民大会是反抗白人统治的领导组织，曼德拉创立了“民族之矛”（Spear of the Nation），这实际上是ANC的武装派别。
And in his kind of career as the leader of the spear of the nation, he became famous for his ability to evade attempts to arrest him. And he becomes fated in the world's press as the black Pimpernel. So he finally arrested in 1962, probably as a result of a tip-off from the CIA. He was convicted of criminal sabotage in 1964 and he gets sentenced to life imprisonment. Gives a great speech as his trial, really moving, rousing speech. Yeah, and so when he goes into prison, he is globally accepted as not just the kind of political, but the moral leader of the campaign against apartheid. And perhaps because of that, initially, he's kept in very brutal conditions.
在他作为“民族之矛”领导人的职业生涯中，他以逃避逮捕的能力而闻名。他在世界媒体中被誉为“黑色红花侠”（Black Pimpernel）。他最终在1962年被捕，很可能是由于中央情报局（CIA）的告密。他在1964年因刑事破坏罪被定罪，并被判处终身监禁。他在审判时发表了一场伟大的演讲，非常感人、激昂的演讲。是的，所以当他入狱时，他被全球公认为不仅是政治领袖，更是反种族隔离运动的道德领袖。也许正因为如此，起初他被关押在非常残酷的条件下。
So he's kept in a tiny cell. He has to wash in icy cold sea water. He's put to hard labour in a stone quarry and the glare of the sun in the quarry is so bright that it permanently damages his eyesight. So very tough conditions. And throughout this period, he never renounces violence. In 1985, the South African government say, look, we'll let you go free if you will renounce violence. And he retorts, only free men can negotiate. Prisoners cannot enter into contracts. he ends up being kept in prison for 27 years, and over the course of those years, he reflects on the limitations of violence. And this, I think, is in large part because of the spiritual, the ideological wellsprings that he's drawing on. So he'd been raised a Methodist. His faith is discreet, but committed, I think. In prison, he very rarely misses a service. He's reading the Bible all the time and he takes seriously what he reads in the Gospels. So the kind of incredibly subversive words of Jesus in the Gospels, love your enemies, and pray for those who persecute you. And when at last,
他被关在一个狭小的牢房里。他必须用冰冷的海水洗澡。他被派去石矿场从事苦役，矿场里阳光的刺眼程度足以永久性地损害他的视力。所以条件非常艰苦。在整个期间，他从未放弃暴力。1985年，南非政府说，看，如果你放弃暴力，我们就让你自由。他反驳道：“只有自由人才能谈判。囚犯不能签订契约。”他最终被关押了27年，在这些年里，他反思了暴力的局限性。我认为这在很大程度上是因为他所汲取的精神和意识形态源泉。他从小是卫理公会教徒。他的信仰是低调但坚定的。在监狱里，他很少错过礼拜。他一直在读圣经，并认真对待他在福音书中读到的内容。所以福音书中耶稣那些极其颠覆性的话语，“爱你的敌人，为那些迫害你的人祈祷”。当最终，
on the 11th of February in 1990, he is freed from prison. He's 71. Amazingly, he returns to the world, determined not just to reclaim his freedom, but to do so in a spirit that is devoid of hatred and bitterness. And he's holding to this philosophy not just as a kind of spiritual discipline, although I think that is absolutely what it is for him, but also because he is a true statesman and he sees this philosophy as the surest way to bind up the kind of the terrible wounds that have been afflicting South Africa for so long. And in short, his aim is to meet the people who had kept him in prison for so long and brutalized his people and discriminated against them. deprived them of every opportunity that they could. He's determined to meet them with forgiveness
在1990年2月11日，他从监狱中获释时。他已经71岁了。令人惊奇的是，他回到这个世界，决心不仅要夺回自己的自由，而且要以一种没有仇恨和痛苦的精神去做。他坚持这种哲学，不仅是作为一种精神纪律，尽管我认为对他来说绝对是这样，而且还因为他是一位真正的政治家，他认为这种哲学是弥合长期以来折磨南非的那些可怕伤口的最佳方式。简而言之，他的目标是去见那些长期将他关在监狱里、残害他的人民、歧视他们、剥夺他们一切机会的人。他决心以宽恕去面对他们，
and he is trusting that they will answer this forgiveness with a mood of repentance. Right. And this essentially is where the Rugby World Cup comes in. So South Africa had been out in the cold in rugby for a long time and more than a decade, which was a massive blow to Afrikan's sense of self-confidence, I think. But it had been readmitted. in 1992 and then awarded the World Cup as a sort of, as a gesture, I guess, you're back in the fold. So they were given the World Cup in 93. And then 1994, they have their first multiracial election, don't they? Properly democratic election.
并相信他们会以悔改的态度来回应这种宽恕。没错。这基本上就是橄榄球世界杯的切入点。南非在橄榄球界被冷落了很长时间，超过十年，我认为这对阿非利卡人的自信心是一个巨大的打击。但它在1992年被重新接纳，然后被授予世界杯主办权，这算是一种姿态，我想，你回来了。所以他们在93年获得了世界杯主办权。然后在1994年，他们进行了第一次多种族选举，不是吗？真正民主的选举。
Yeah, so they get the World Cup before the election. Yeah. But in the expectation, of course, that things are going to change politically in South Africa, which they do, because the African National Congress, Mandela's party, wins a, landslide majority in the first election. And Mandela becomes the first black president. And his relationship with rugby and the way in which he uses it is actually a really, really interesting example of the political use of sports.
是的，他们在选举前获得了世界杯。是的。但当然是基于南非政治将会发生变化的预期，事实也确实如此，因为曼德拉所在的非洲人国民大会在第一次选举中赢得了压倒性多数。曼德拉成为了第一位黑人总统。他与橄榄球的关系以及他利用橄榄球的方式，实际上是体育政治用途的一个非常、非常有趣的例子。
Yeah, because South Africa would never have been given the Rugby World Cup, had Mandela and the ANC not essentially given it the green light even before they become the government. And as you say, Mandela has picked up on the significance that rugby plays in the kind of Afrikaner soul. And by the way, you can't emphasize enough how unusual this is because black South Africans did not, by and large, support the Springbok rugby team. Their sport was not rugby. It was football.
是的，因为如果曼德拉和非国大在他们成为政府之前没有给予绿灯，南非永远不会获得橄榄球世界杯。正如你所说，曼德拉已经意识到了橄榄球在阿非利卡人灵魂中所扮演的重要意义。顺便说一句，你无法过度强调这有多么不寻常，因为南非黑人总体上并不支持跳羚橄榄球队。他们的运动不是橄榄球。是足球。
Rugby was the game of the oppressor. So for Mandela to have any interest in this at all is groundbreaking, it's stunning. Well, it's part of a kind of broader program of self-education that Mandela puts himself through in prison, to try, basically to try and understand the enemy. So he is learning Afrikaans. He's learning about the history of the Afrikaners, their heroes, their mythology, you know, how they understand their role in Africa. Because of course, by this point, they have been in Africa for centuries and centuries. So they are essentially an African people. And Mandela absolutely kind of recognizes that, that they have to be part of the settlement
橄榄球是压迫者的游戏。所以曼德拉对此有任何兴趣都是开创性的，令人震惊的。嗯，这是曼德拉在狱中对自己进行的一种更广泛的自我教育计划的一部分，基本上是为了试图了解敌人。所以他在学习南非荷兰语。他在学习阿非利卡人的历史、他们的英雄、他们的神话，你知道，他们如何理解自己在非洲的角色。因为当然，到这个时候，他们已经在非洲生活了几个世纪。所以他们本质上是一个非洲民族。曼德拉绝对认可这一点，即他们必须成为曼德拉希望达成的和解的一部分。
that Mandela is hoping will come. And so as well as studying African people, history, he also tries to befriend his jailers. He treats them with respect in the expectation, which increasingly the longer he's in prison comes to be met, that the jailers will treat him with respect in return. And he ends up great friends in particular with one guard, Christo Brand. And it's Brand who in the late 1980s starts to educate Mandela in rugby. As you said, it's not just about the rules, it's not just about the players, it's about the role that it plays in Africana culture. And so Mandela comes out of prison entirely understanding how potentially significant rugby might be.
因此，除了研究非洲人民和历史外，他还试图与他的狱卒交朋友。他以尊重的态度对待他们，并期待着——随着他在监狱里待的时间越长，这种期待就越能得到满足——狱卒们也会以同样的尊重来回报他。他最终与一名狱卒克里斯托·布兰德（Christo Brand）成为了好朋友。正是布兰德在80年代末开始向曼德拉普及橄榄球知识。正如你所说，这不仅仅是关于规则，不仅仅是关于球员，而是关于它在阿非利卡文化中扮演的角色。所以曼德拉出狱时，完全理解橄榄球可能具有的重大意义。
And he sees, I think, the World Cup as a way of securing two separate goals. So the first is that it might help win the support of Afrikaners, who are the most inveterate opponents of accommodation with black majority rule. It might help them kind of accept this new multiracial settlement. As you said, for most black Africans, rugby is the archetypal sport of the white oppressor, the Afrikaner oppressor. And so radicals in the ANC, they want to see, for instance, the distinctive green jersey of the Springboks band. They want to see the name Springbox band as well. And they push this demand and Mandela flatly refuses. Mandela has also made a point of reaching out to the captain of the Springbox, who,
我认为他将世界杯视为实现两个独立目标的途径。首先，它可能有助于赢得阿非利卡人的支持，他们是与黑人多数统治达成妥协的最顽固的反对者。这可能有助于他们接受这种新的多种族和解。正如你所说，对于大多数南非黑人来说，橄榄球是白人压迫者、阿非利卡压迫者的原型运动。因此，非国大内部的激进分子希望看到，例如，跳羚队独特的绿色球衣被禁止。他们也希望看到“跳羚”这个名字被禁止。他们推动这一要求，但曼德拉断然拒绝。曼德拉还特意接触了跳羚队的队长，
who is a guy called Francois Pinaar, getting Pinar on board with the exciting, progressive new slogan for the South African rugby team, one team, one country. And Pinar is essentially what AI would come up with if you typed in Africana rugby player. You know, he doesn't really look like Matt Damon who plays him in Invictus and who just looks so unbelievably American. It's not true. Pinar looks very, very South African. He looks incredibly hard, doesn't he? He's from a working-class transvaal family. So he's from one of the kind of great Afrikanah heartlands.
一个叫弗朗索瓦·皮纳尔（Francois Pienaar）的人，让皮纳尔加入南非橄榄球队那个令人兴奋、进步的新口号：“一个团队，一个国家”（One team, one country）。皮纳尔基本上就是如果你输入“阿非利卡橄榄球运动员”AI会给出的形象。你知道，他看起来并不像在《成事在人》中饰演他的马特·达蒙，后者看起来太不可思议地美国化了。那不是真的。皮纳尔看起来非常、非常南非。他看起来极其强硬，不是吗？他来自一个工人阶级的德兰士瓦家庭。所以他来自阿非利卡人的核心地带之一。
And he looks like it's hewn out of wood or something. Very blonde, incredibly tall, gigantic, an absolute alpha male. But he's very smart. He's educated. And he's a deeply Christian man. And he is invited to the presidential palace for tea meets Mandela. Is completely charmed by Mandela. And Mandela, in turn, is very impressive.
他看起来像是用木头雕刻出来的。非常金发，高得不可思议，巨大，绝对的阿尔法男性。但他很聪明。他受过教育。而且他是一个虔诚的基督徒。他被邀请到总统府喝茶，见到了曼德拉。完全被曼德拉的人格魅力所折服。而曼德拉反过来也对他印象深刻。
with Pina, said about him, he did not seem to me at all to be the typical product of an apartheid society. It was a pleasure to sit down with him. And Pinar buys into Mandela's kind of goal. And between them, they managed to get the rest of the spring box on board so that by the time the World Cup comes around, all the South African team are aware of their mission, which essentially is not just to win the tournament, although that would be a massive bonus, but essentially to serve as symbols of the new Africa, you know, one team, one nation. But it's not just about winning the support of white South Africans for the new constitution for Mandela. He also has another goal, and this is much more difficult, which is to get black South Africans to back the spring box
关于皮纳尔，他说：“他给我的感觉一点也不像是种族隔离社会的典型产物。和他坐下来交谈是一种乐趣。”皮纳尔接受了曼德拉的目标。他们两人设法让其余的跳羚队队员也加入进来，以至于当世界杯到来时，所有南非队员都意识到了他们的使命，这本质上不仅是赢得比赛，尽管那将是一个巨大的奖励，而是本质上作为新非洲的象征，你知道，“一个团队，一个国家”。但这不仅仅是为了让南非白人支持曼德拉的新宪法。他还有另一个目标，这要困难得多，那就是让南非黑人支持跳羚队
as their team, as their boys. Yeah. I mean, obviously they hate the spring box because they were seen as a symbol of apartheid. But as you said, it's also because football is the mass game for black South Africans. Most black South Africans don't understand rugby. And those who did understand it, if they watch a rugby match, an international rugby match, would always, as a point of principle, support the Springbok's opponents. And it is an issue that going into the 1995 tournament, the South African team only has one non-white player in the entire squad.
作为他们的球队，作为“他们的男孩”。是的。我的意思是，显然他们讨厌跳羚队，因为他们被视为种族隔离的象征。但正如你所说，这也是因为足球是南非黑人的大众运动。大多数南非黑人不了解橄榄球。而那些了解它的人，如果他们观看橄榄球比赛，一场国际橄榄球比赛，作为原则，他们总是会支持跳羚队的对手。这是一个问题，在1995年锦标赛开始时，南非队整个阵容中只有一名非白人球员。
And this is a guy called Chester Williams. Chester Williams, who is known as the Black Pearl. So it is, I think, for Mandela are a massive. Gamble. He's got to get the white rugby supporters backing the new multiracial settlement and he's got to get the black South Africans supporting the Springboks as an emblem of this New South Africa. So how does he do it? I mean the key thing obviously is they win the World Cup. Yeah, that's not a huge help, isn't it? So there is a conspiracy theory, isn't there? I know we have some listeners in New Zealand and they will be absolutely pulling their hair out at this point and
这是一个叫切斯特·威廉姆斯（Chester Williams）的人。切斯特·威廉姆斯，被称为“黑珍珠”。所以，我认为这对曼德拉来说是一场巨大的赌博。他必须让白人橄榄球支持者支持新的多种族和解，并且他必须让南非黑人支持跳羚队，将其作为这个新南非的象征。那么他是怎么做到的呢？我的意思是，关键显然是他们赢得了世界杯。是的，那不是一个巨大的帮助吗？所以有一个阴谋论，不是吗？我知道我们在新西兰有一些听众，他们此时一定会气得抓狂，
throwing their phones across the room because they will tell you, Tom, that their team were poisoned before the game, they had food poisoning. So like Gordon Banks. Yeah, well, much more than Gordon Banks. So a lot of the team, they say had food poisoning. They were poisoned by the South Africans, and that's what the South Africans want. Now, at this point, South African listeners will be going mad.
把手机扔过房间，因为他们会告诉你，汤姆，他们的球队在比赛前被下毒了，他们食物中毒了。就像戈登·班克斯（Gordon Banks）那样。是的，比戈登·班克斯的情况严重得多。所以他们说球队里的很多人食物中毒了。他们被南非人下毒了，而这就是南非人想要的。现在，此时南非听众会气疯的。
Well, their manager said that it was dodgy milk. Yeah. I mean, what is definitely a factor, I think, is the presence of Mandela himself. Huge. Yeah. At the match. And Mandela, who's an incredibly cunning,
嗯，他们的经理说是牛奶变质了。是的。我的意思是，我认为绝对的一个因素是曼德拉本人的出席。巨大的。是的。在比赛现场。而曼德拉，他是一个极其狡猾、
cunning operator at every level. I mean, he plays a blinder. So before the tournament begins, he does everything he can to get the ANC, the kind of larger black constituency beyond them in South Africa, backing the spring box. He's absolutely insisting this is not a time for school settling. This is a time for generosity. He goes to the spring box training camp before the tournament begins. He shakes all the hands of the various players. He's made sure he knows what their names are.
狡猾的操盘手，在各个层面上。我的意思是，他下了一步好棋。所以在锦标赛开始前，他尽其所能让非国大，让南非更广泛的黑人选民支持跳羚队。他坚决主张现在不是算旧账的时候。现在是慷慨的时候。他在锦标赛开始前去了跳羚队的训练营。他与各位球员握手。他确保自己知道他们的名字。
He addresses them by name. And then he goes out and he publicly. urges everyone in South Africa to back them. He says, we have adopted these young men as our boys, as our own children, as our own stars. And it helps, as you say, that the spring box keep winning and winning and winning and they end up in the final. Mandela's most iconic performance of all comes on the day of the final because he turns up very famously wearing a spring box shirt, the green shirt that had been an emblem of apartheid for so many decades. And on it he has the number six, which is penas number on the back.
他直呼他们的名字。然后他走出去，公开敦促南非的每个人支持他们。他说：“我们已经收养了这些年轻人作为我们的男孩，作为我们自己的孩子，作为我们自己的明星。”正如你所说，跳羚队不断获胜，最终进入了决赛，这很有帮助。曼德拉最标志性的表现出现在决赛当天，因为他非常出名地穿着一件跳羚队的球衣，那件几十年来一直是种族隔离象征的绿色球衣。上面印着6号，那是皮纳尔的号码。
And wearing this green shirt, he goes down into the bowels of this immense stadium. And first of all, he visits the all blacks in their dressing room. And then he goes to see the spring box. And this has a huge psychological impact on both teams because the all blacks, to have the man who's probably the most admired person in the world at this point turn up in a spring box journey. I mean, their synapses are absolutely fizzing with this. They can't kind of synthesise it.
穿着这件绿色球衣，他走进了这座巨大体育场的深处。首先，他访问了全黑队在更衣室。然后他去看了跳羚队。这对两支球队都产生了巨大的心理影响，因为对于全黑队来说，让当时世界上最受钦佩的人穿着跳羚队的球衣出现。我的意思是，他们的神经绝对因为这个而兴奋。他们无法理解这一点。
And it's reported that Lomu was daunted to meet Mandela, and perhaps this had a kind of dispiriting impact on him. Whereas for the springbacks, of course, they are massively inspired by meeting Mandela. But the greatest moment is yet to come, because Mandela, after he's been to the dressing rooms, then steps out onto the rugby pitch itself, onto the field of what Carlin in his book describes as Afrikanaderms, Holy of Holies, the National Rugby Stadium. And it could so easily have gone wrong.
据报道，洛穆在见到曼德拉时感到畏缩，也许这对他产生了一种令人沮丧的影响。而对于跳羚队来说，他们当然因为见到曼德拉而深受鼓舞。但最伟大的时刻还在后面，因为曼德拉在去过更衣室后，走上了橄榄球场，走上了卡林在书中描述的“阿非利卡人的圣地”，国家橄榄球体育场。这很容易出错。
He could have been booed. I mean, worst of all, he could have been shot. You know, there might have been a kind of, you know, a racist sniper up there in the stands. But it's a triumph. And the overwhelmingly African a crowd start chanting Nelson Nelson so it's like us when we're talking about the Battle of Trafalgar and you can hear it on the on on on YouTube it's a kind of amazing kind of rapturous greeting of a man who by most of the people in that stadium had been seen as a terrorist only a few years before and Mandela takes off his cap he waves it in the air you see it on the on YouTube he's smiling he's looking as as as happy as it's possible for man to look. Amory DePlessy, who was the spring box manager, great former South African rugby player.
他可能会被嘘。我的意思是，最糟糕的是，他可能会被枪杀。你知道，看台上可能有一个种族主义狙击手。但这是一个胜利。绝大多数阿非利卡人观众开始高呼“纳尔逊，纳尔逊”，所以这就像我们谈论特拉法尔加海战时一样，你可以在YouTube上听到它，这是一种令人惊叹的、狂喜的问候，问候一个在几年前还被体育场里大多数人视为恐怖分子的人。曼德拉摘下帽子，他在空中挥舞，你在YouTube上可以看到，他在微笑，他看起来像是一个人所能表现出的最快乐的样子。阿莫里·德普莱西（Amory DePlessis），他是跳羚队的经理，伟大的前南非橄榄球运动员。
Former captain, yeah. He said it of this moment. It was a moment of magic, a moment of wonder. It was the moment I realized that there really was a chance this country could work. This man was showing that he could forgive totally. And now they, white side Africa, rugby white side Africa, they showed in their response to him that they too wanted to give back. Oh, that's a very good version of the accent that people around. the world have come to love. Thank you. Maybe he's a rugby player.
前队长，是的。他这样评价这一刻：“这是一个神奇的时刻，一个奇迹的时刻。那一刻我意识到，这个国家真的有机会成功。这个人展示了他可以完全宽恕。”现在他们，白人南非，橄榄球白人南非，他们在对他的回应中表明，他们也想给予回报。哦，那是人们在世界各地所爱的那种口音的一个非常好的版本。谢谢。也许他是个橄榄球运动员。
I should have made it sound slightly more formidable. So, yeah, it sounded familiar. I was focusing on the vowels. Yeah, it sounded formidable in a slightly camway. Anyway, the clock shakes out towards the start of the match. And of course, you know, it's a final of a World Cup. And they're going to begin by seeing their national anthems. So a tense moment.
我应该让它听起来稍微更具威慑力一点。所以，是的，听起来很熟悉。我专注于元音。是的，它听起来在某种程度上很威严。无论如何，时钟指向比赛开始。当然，你知道，这是世界杯决赛。他们将以唱国歌开始。所以这是一个紧张的时刻。
Well, not just tense. I mean, it is the most symbolically freighted moment of this. the entire match, the entire tournament, perhaps the entire spell of time since Mandela had been released from prison. So the two teams, New Zealand and South Africa, they have to sing their respective national anthems. And of course, the tension, you could cut with a knife, Dominic, to coin a phrase. So we have the Imalongi Cantu Choral Society who are going to be taking the lead in singing the anthems. And they are a black choir from Soweto, which is the sprawling township outside Johannesburg where the Rugby World Cup final is being held and it had long served as the effective
嗯，不仅仅是紧张。我的意思是，这是整个比赛、整个锦标赛，甚至可能是曼德拉出狱以来这段时间里，最具象征意义的时刻。所以两支球队，新西兰队和南非队，必须唱各自的国歌。当然，多米尼克，借用一句俗话，那种紧张气氛简直可以用刀切开。所以我们有伊马隆吉·坎图合唱团（Imalongi Cantu Choral Society）来领唱国歌。他们是一个来自索韦托的黑人合唱团，索韦托是约翰内斯堡郊外的一个庞大的城镇，橄榄球世界杯决赛就在那里举行，长期以来，它实际上一直是反种族隔离运动的中心。
capital of the anti-apartheid movement. On top of that, this choir is going to be singing a song that had only been South Africa's national anthem for a year since the election of the ANC government. And this is Kosei Sicolalia Africa. And it's a song that to Afrikaners had long symbolized subversion, revolution, terrorism, black power, everything that the apartheid regime had been committed to suppressing very brutally. And to reiterate, we are now in the great cathedral of Afrikanerdom. So obviously, the Springboks had sung it before. It had preceded previous matches, but never in a place, a time, a fixture with the amount of the amount of the same. of symbolic weight that this match had.
最重要的是，这个合唱团要唱的一首歌，自非国大政府当选以来，仅仅作为南非国歌一年。这就是《上帝保佑非洲》（Nkosi Sikelel' iAfrika）。对于南非白人来说，这首歌长期以来象征着颠覆、革命、恐怖主义、黑人权力，以及种族隔离政权一直致力于残酷镇压的一切。重申一下，我们现在身处南非白人至上主义的大教堂里。所以很明显，跳羚队以前唱过这首歌。它在之前的比赛前也唱过，但从来没有在这样一个地方、这样一个时间、这样一个具有如此多象征意义的比赛中唱过。
So what's it going to mean for them to sing this anthem? But even more pressingly, perhaps, how is the crowd in this great stadium overwhelmingly Afrikaner? How are they going to react with the eyes of the world upon them? Yeah, and what about the anthem itself? Enkosi Sicilele Africa. Where has it come from and how has it ended up becoming this great anthem of Black Liberation?
那么，对他们来说，唱这首国歌意味着什么呢？但也许更紧迫的是，这个伟大的体育场里绝大多数是南非白人观众，他们会作何反应？当全世界的目光都注视着他们时，他们会怎么做？是的，那这首国歌本身呢？《上帝保佑非洲》。它从哪里来，又是如何最终成为这首伟大的黑人解放赞歌的？
Well, we'll be answering all these questions after the break. This episode is brought to you by Lloyds. Now, when you have ambitions, being able to see the bigger picture is just so important. And history definitely teaches us that. My favorite example, not necessarily a brilliant man, but the Spanish conquistador Hernan Cortez. He was a visionary, he was an adventurer, but he also grasped that the empire of the Aztecs was vulnerable, and he took his men in land, and he was able to bring down the Aztecs with just a handful of men. And of course, this isn't just a problem for blood-soaked conquistadors. It is true for the rest of us as well, which is where Lloyd's comes in.
好吧，休息之后我们将回答所有这些问题。本期节目由劳埃德银行（Lloyds）赞助。当你拥有雄心壮志时，能够看到大局是非常重要的。历史确实教会了我们这一点。我最喜欢的例子，不一定是一个聪明人，但西班牙征服者埃尔南·科尔特斯（Hernan Cortez）。他是一位有远见的人，是一位冒险家，但他同时也抓住了阿兹特克帝国脆弱的弱点，他带着他的人深入内陆，仅凭少数人就推翻了阿兹特克帝国。当然，这不仅仅是血腥的征服者面临的问题，对我们其他人来说也是如此，这就是劳埃德银行的用武之地。
Their app helps you to see all your finances in one place so that you can feel clearer and more confident about what comes next. And rather like Cortez, you're managing the micro and the macro. So one moment, you might be managing day-to-day spending with budgeting insights using the app, or you might be getting guidance if you're thinking about starting a lot. business. So whatever your next move looks like, you can bank on Lloyd's to help you make it with confidence. Visit lloydsbank.com. Hi everybody, it's Dominic Sanbrook here. There are two weeks to go until the rest is history's inaugural festival at Hampton Court Palace. And frankly, I could not
他们的应用程序可以帮助你在一处查看所有财务状况，让你对未来感到更清晰、更自信。就像科尔特斯一样，你既要管理微观，也要管理宏观。所以，有时你可能正在使用该应用程序的预算洞察来管理日常支出，或者如果你正在考虑创办一家企业，你可能会获得指导。因此，无论你的下一步是什么，你都可以信赖劳埃德银行，帮助你自信地迈出这一步。请访问 lloydsbank.com。大家好，我是多米尼克·桑布鲁克。距离“历史的其余部分”（The Rest is History）在汉普顿宫举办的首届艺术节还有两周时间。坦率地说，我再兴奋不过了。
be more excited. There's going to be medieval combat. There are going to be all sorts of big-name historians. You can go to the palace. You can feast like Henry VIII on the very lawns where he walked. In the sunshine, I'll be talking to Tracy Borman about the Tudors. I'll be talking to Katia Hoyer about Vimar Germany. I'll be talking to Ian Hisslop about the history of satire. So it's on two days. It's on Saturday the 4th of July and Sunday the 5th of July. The bad news is we have actually sold out the allocations that we were given by Hampton Court for both days. The good news, however, we have persuaded Hampton Court to let us have more people. So there will be a handful of extra tickets available for both the Saturday and the Sunday.
届时将会有中世纪的格斗表演。会有各种大牌历史学家出席。你可以去宫殿。你可以在亨利八世曾经走过的草坪上像他一样享用盛宴。在阳光下，我将与特蕾西·博曼（Tracy Borman）谈论都铎王朝。我将与卡蒂亚·霍耶（Katia Hoyer）谈论魏玛德国。我将与伊恩·希斯洛普（Ian Hislop）谈论讽刺的历史。所以活动为期两天。是在7月4日星期六和7月5日星期日。坏消息是，我们实际上已经卖光了汉普顿宫为这两天分配给我们的门票。然而好消息是，我们已经说服汉普顿宫让我们接待更多的人。所以周六和周日都会有少量的额外门票。
Now we do expect all of those extra tickets to sell out really quickly. So please do not wait to get your hands on them. The tickets are exclusive for club members. It's one of the benefits of being a member of the Restis History Club. Frankly, if you're not a member and you would like to go to the festival, the only way to do that is by joining the club. So you have to head to therestishistory.com to sign up. and then you go to the members area once you've signed up
我们确实预计所有这些额外门票会很快售罄。所以请不要等待，尽快抢购。这些门票是俱乐部会员专享的。这是成为“历史的其余部分”俱乐部会员的好处之一。坦率地说，如果你不是会员，又想去参加艺术节，唯一的办法就是加入俱乐部。所以你必须前往 therestishistory.com 注册。注册后，你进入会员区，
and you select festival to get your tickets. We are really hoping to see as many of you there as possible in the sunshine, a Hampton court. Bye-bye. Hello and welcome back to The Rest is History. So this is the sixth, the Nagrae series, tying in with the World Cup, looking at the stories behind the national anthems
然后选择艺术节来获取你的门票。我们真的希望在汉普顿宫的阳光下尽可能多地见到你们。再见。你好，欢迎回到“历史的其余部分”。这是与世界杯相关的第六个系列节目，探讨参赛国家国歌背后的故事。
for some of the competing nations. And today we are looking at the story of Nkosi, Sicilele, Africa, perhaps the most beautiful of all the African national anthems that people will be hearing at the FIFA World Cup, and certainly the most celebrated and the most historically fascinating. The interesting thing, though, is that, you know, we've done some anthems in this series, the origins of which are kind of shrouded in obscurity. So, you know, it's sometimes hard to tell exactly where they've come from. For example, God Save the King. Exactly who wrote it, we can't be sure. Same story with the Vilhelmus, the national anthem of the Netherlands.
今天我们要看的是《上帝保佑非洲》的故事，这可能是人们在国际足联世界杯上听到的所有非洲国歌中最美的一首，当然也是最著名、历史上最迷人的一首。不过有趣的是，你知道，我们在本系列中做过一些国歌，它们的起源有点模糊。所以，你知道，有时很难说清楚它们到底来自哪里。例如，《天佑国王》。到底是谁写的，我们无法确定。荷兰国歌《威廉颂》也是如此。
But we do know who wrote this anthem, and it's a man called Enoch Sontonga, isn't it, Tom? Yes. So he is the writer. And he was born in the early 1870s, in the Eastern Cape Colony. And like Mandela, he was a native Lhosa speaker. And again, I hope I've got the click right there. He moves northwards to Johannesburg and he becomes a teacher in a Methodist school in what will ultimately become the great township of Soweto outside Johannesburg. So you would think a teacher in a Methodist school in the 1880s and 1890s unlikely to be a dandy.
但我们确实知道是谁写了这首国歌，是一个叫伊诺克·桑通加（Enoch Sontonga）的人，对吧，汤姆？是的。所以他是作者。他出生于19世纪70年代初，在东开普殖民地。和曼德拉一样，他是科萨语母语者。再说一次，我希望我发对了那个搭嘴音。他向北搬到约翰内斯堡，成为一所卫理公会学校的老师，这所学校最终成为了约翰内斯堡郊外伟大的索韦托城镇。所以你可能会认为19世纪80年代和90年代卫理公会学校的老师不太可能是个花花公子。
But in St Tonga's case, you'd be wrong because there is a photograph showing him looking unbelievably natty. He's got a hat. He's got a three-piece suit. Must have been very hot in the South African Sun. Very naty pocket square. And he's holding the chain of a fob watch. I mean, he looks very, very stylish indeed. We know incredibly little about him.
但在桑通加的例子中，你就错了，因为有一张照片显示他看起来极其时髦。他戴着帽子。他穿着三件套西装。在南非的阳光下一定很热。非常时髦的口袋方巾。他手里拿着怀表的链子。我的意思是，他看起来确实非常、非常时尚。我们对他知之甚少。
We don't even know what he taught. But we do know that he runs the school choir, and he's always writing songs for it. So he's clearly very musical. And one of these songs, which he scribbles down on a scrap of paper in 1897, is the song that becomes Cozy Sicolalei, Africa, the song that will make him famous. But this fame is entirely posthumous because in 1905, Sontanga, he's 32, he starts to get afflicted by stomach cramps.
我们甚至不知道他教什么。但我们确实知道他负责学校合唱团，而且他一直在为合唱团写歌。所以他显然非常有音乐天赋。其中一首歌，他在1897年写在一张纸条上，就是后来成为《上帝保佑非洲》的歌，这首歌让他成名。但这种名声完全是死后的，因为1905年，桑通加32岁时，开始受到胃痉挛的折磨。
And they are so hideous that actually gets into the local newspaper. He's suffering so badly. And the newspaper wrote, he suffered at times from stomachache to the extent that he would predict that these were his last days on this earth. And he's right. Yeah. Because he dies shortly afterwards of gastroenteritis. And he's buried in the section of the Bramfontein graveyard in Johannesburg, which is reserved for black Christians. So the racism is evident even in cemeteries.
而且它们非常可怕，甚至登上了当地报纸。他痛苦不堪。报纸写道，他有时胃痛到预测这是他在这个地球上的最后日子。他是对的。是的。因为他不久后死于肠胃炎。他被埋葬在约翰内斯堡布拉姆方丹墓地（Bramfontein graveyard）为黑人基督徒预留的部分。所以种族主义即使在墓地里也很明显。
And in due course, the very location of his grave comes to be forgotten. And that is pretty much the sum total of what we know about him. So we do know, you know, we know who wrote this song, but, you know, the life of the composer is pretty much failed in obscurity. And if we go to the song itself, written in Corsa, and it means Lord Bless Africa, one verse and a chorus, right? That's all there is. Yes. And these words are, as well as the music, Sontong has written the words, as you say, a single verse, Lord bless Africa. May her glory be lifted high. Here are petitions. Lord, bless us, your children. And then there's chorus, descend, O Spirit, descend, O Holy Spirit. So, I mean, very evident. a hymn, an anthem, if you like, and expressive of a kind of a broader trend in South African Christianity at the time Sontonga writes it. So white missionaries have been spreading Christianity in South Africa and among black South Africans over the course of the centuries. And by the
久而久之，他墓地的具体位置也被遗忘了。这几乎就是我们对他所知的一切。所以我们确实知道，你知道，我们知道是谁写了这首歌，但是，你知道，作曲家的生活几乎被遗忘了。如果我们谈到这首歌本身，用科萨语写成，意思是“上帝保佑非洲”，一节歌词和一个副歌，对吧？这就是全部。是的。这些词，以及音乐，桑通加写了词，正如你所说，只有一节，上帝保佑非洲。愿她的荣耀被高举。听我们的祈求。上帝，保佑我们，你的孩子们。然后是副歌，降临吧，哦圣灵，降临吧，哦圣灵。所以，我的意思是，非常明显。一首赞美诗，如果你愿意的话，一首国歌，表达了桑通加创作时南非基督教的一种更广泛的趋势。所以白人传教士几个世纪以来一直在南非和南非黑人中传播基督教。到了
end of the 19th century, black Christians in South Africa are, I think, coming to resent the kind of the mood, the spirit, the vibe of paternalism with which they are being treated by white missionaries, by the predominantly white-led churches. And in reaction to this, they start to emphasize the antiquity of African Christianity and to argue that Christianity has been a presence in Africa for much longer than it had been, for instance, in either Britain or the Netherlands. But they're all wrong. They're not wrong because they can focus specifically on Ethiopia. here. The kings of Ethiopia, people who listened to the episode we did on the Ark of the Covenant, may remember that the Ethiopian kings claim to be descended from Solomon and the queen of Sheba.
19世纪末，南非的黑人基督徒，我想，开始反感白人传教士、以白人为主导的教会对待他们时那种家长式作风的情绪、精神和氛围。作为对此的回应，他们开始强调非洲基督教的古老性，并争辩说基督教在非洲的存在时间比在英国或荷兰等国要长得多。但他们都错了。他们没有错，因为他们可以专门关注埃塞俄比亚。这里。埃塞俄比亚的国王，听过我们关于约柜那一集的人可能记得，埃塞俄比亚国王声称是所罗门和示巴女王的后裔。
And in the Psalms, it had been prophesied that Ethiopia would quickly stretch out her hands to God. And in South Africa, Ethiopia comes to be a kind of synonymism for the whole of Africa. And in the Acts of the Apostles, South Africans can read that one of the very first Gentile converts is an Ethiopian eunuch. And as they say, you know, there's no Dutch, there's no British converts in the Acts of the Apostles. But an African convert, yes, there absolutely is. And so in 1892, five years before Sontanga writes in Kosovo, Africa, a breakaway Christian movement has been founded by a Zulu. Methodist minister, and this is called the Ethiopian Church. And so this is very much the spiritual climate in which Sontonga is living. And it's a climate in which it's taken for granted by
在《诗篇》中，曾预言埃塞俄比亚会迅速向神伸出双手。在南非，埃塞俄比亚成为了整个非洲的代名词。在《使徒行传》中，南非人可以读到，最早的外邦人皈依者之一是一位埃塞俄比亚太监。正如他们所说，你知道，《使徒行传》里没有荷兰人，没有英国人皈依者。但有一位非洲皈依者，是的，绝对有。因此，在1892年，即桑通加写《上帝保佑非洲》的五年前，一个祖鲁族卫理公会牧师创立了一个分裂的基督教运动，这被称为埃塞俄比亚教会。所以这非常符合桑通加所处的精神气候。在这种气候下，黑人非洲人认为这是理所当然的，
black Africans that God holds Africa especially in his care, that he has plotted out a particular path for Christianity in black Africa. The hymn that Sontonga writes is Pentecostal, meaning that it describes the Holy Spirit descending like fire. And this is entirely appropriate because the popularity of the hymn itself spreads like wildfire. And in 1912, it sung at the inaugural meeting of a crucial convention. This is a meeting of the South African Native National Congress. And this was held in Blumfontein, and it is attended by chiefs and other leading black figures from across the country. And the aim of this Congress is to oppose.
上帝特别关照非洲，他为黑人非洲的基督教规划了一条特殊的道路。桑通加写的这首赞美诗是五旬节派的，意思是它描述了圣灵像火一样降临。这完全恰当，因为这首赞美诗本身的流行像野火一样蔓延。1912年，它在一次关键会议的开幕式上被演唱。这是南非土著国民大会（South African Native National Congress）的一次会议。会议在布隆方丹举行，全国各地的酋长和其他主要黑人人物出席了会议。这次大会的目的是反对
attempts by white legislators to introduce what in retrospect will very clearly come to seem one of the kind of the building blocks of what will be the apartheid regime and specifically it's essentially about enabling the whites to take the best bits of land in South Africa so it's it's a native land act that's what it's called and it allocates the ownership of 90% of South African land and exclusively to whites. You know, blacks can have the remaining 10%, which is all scrubby and rubbish and, you know, not fertile.
白人立法者试图引入后来回顾时显然会成为种族隔离政权基石之一的东西，具体来说，它本质上是关于使白人能够夺取南非最好的土地，所以它是一个《土著土地法》，这就是它的名字，它将90%的南非土地所有权专门分配给白人。你知道，黑人只能拥有剩下的10%，全是灌木丛和垃圾，你知道，不肥沃。
So you can understand why flat leaders are meeting up to oppose this. Inevitably, it fails. This Natives Land Act is passed the following year, so in 1913. But the members of the Congress don't give up, and they're determined to continue the fight. And in 1923, they changed the name of their organisation. to a much more inclusive one and indeed much snappier. And so what had been the South African Native National Congress becomes the African National Congress.
所以你可以理解为什么黑人领袖们聚在一起反对这一点。不可避免地，它失败了。这个《土著土地法》在次年，即1913年通过了。但大会成员没有放弃，他们决心继续战斗。1923年，他们更改了组织的名称，改为一个更具包容性，确实也更响亮的名字。于是，原来的南非土著国民大会变成了非洲人国民大会（African National Congress）。
So you don't have to be a South African native. Anyone can join it. It's open to everyone. And it's two years after that that Enkozi is adopted as the ANC's official anthem. And it's quite, it's not maybe an obvious answer. Anthem because we said in the previous episode that we did on the Brazilian National Anthem that a lot of national anthems are really quite violent. They are, they need an enemy. And you'd think that the A&C might be tempted to go for an anthem in which the white rulers of South Africa are being damned. But not a bit of it, because there's actually very, you know, there's nothing martial, there's nothing aggressive, there's nothing militant about the lyrics of Enkozi, Sicilele Africa at all.
所以你不必是南非土著。任何人都可以加入。它对所有人开放。两年后，这首歌被采纳为非国大的正式国歌。这可能不是一个显而易见的国歌，因为我们在上一集关于巴西国歌的节目中说过，很多国歌其实相当暴力。它们是，它们需要一个敌人。你可能会认为非国大可能会倾向于选择一首南非白人统治者被诅咒的国歌。但一点也不，因为实际上，你知道，歌词中没有任何尚武、没有任何侵略性、没有任何激进的东西。
And even when in 1927 a hosa poet adds seven extra verses to it, because one verse is decided it's not enough, I mean, it still remains a hymn. The tone of the song remains kind of pacific in the way that it has previously been. But that kind of works, doesn't take it from the nature of their struggle? I mean, the struggle is punctuated with moments of martyrdom, with massacres, with funerals and trials and, you know, and suffering. The story of the ANC is a story about victory through suffering, and that's why this, as a hymn, it works really well. Yeah, so people who are being executed,
即使在1927年，一位科萨诗人为它增加了七节额外的歌词，因为人们认为一节不够，我的意思是，它仍然是一首赞美诗。这首歌的基调在某种程度上保持了之前的和平。但这是否削弱了他们斗争的性质？我的意思是，斗争中穿插着殉道、大屠杀、葬礼和审判，你知道，还有苦难。非国大的故事是一个通过苦难获得胜利的故事，这就是为什么这首歌作为赞美诗效果非常好。是的，所以那些被处决的人，
A&C members who are being executed, as they, you know, are standing on the trap door that will drop and, you know, they'll kind of fall through the trap door. They are singing it. And in a sense, the fact that it's not aggressive, it's not violent, that it's a kind of hymn to God. I agree, it makes it kind of all the more powerful. But equally, you can see why to,
被处决的非国大成员，当他们站在活板门上，活板门会掉下来，你知道，他们会掉下去。他们正在唱这首歌。从某种意义上说，它不具有侵略性，不暴力，它是一种对上帝的赞美诗。我同意，这让它变得更加强大。但同样，你可以理解为什么对于
the agents of the apartheid regime, the hymn of the ANC comes to seem something very menacing, something very aggressive. Well, not least because they can't understand it. Can't really understand it. And so they assume that it's a song that's kind of suffused with hate. And it comes to seem emblematic of everything that they're fighting. They really, really mistrust and dislike it. The idea that it might end up is the anthem of South Africa, just kind of monstrous possible. not least because the apartheid state has its own national anthem, Dishdem van
种族隔离政权的代理人来说，非国大的赞美诗变得看起来非常具有威胁性，非常具有侵略性。嗯，至少因为他们听不懂。真的听不懂。所以他们认为这是一首充满仇恨的歌。它成为了他们所对抗的一切的象征。他们真的、真的非常不信任和不喜欢它。它最终可能成为南非国歌的想法，简直是极其荒谬的。不仅因为种族隔离国家有自己的国歌，《南非之声》（Die Stem van Suid-Afrika）。就像南非白人讨厌非国大的国歌一样，南非黑人也开始讨厌种族隔离的国歌，我的意思是，完全可以理解。事实上，就像《上帝保佑非洲》的歌词一样，那些《南非之声》的歌词其实基调相当柔和。所以里面提到了一次牛车（Oxwagon）的呻吟。而且，这是对“大迁徙”（Voortrekkers）的隐喻，即19世纪试图逃避英国统治的布尔人。所以从开普殖民地迁移到南非内陆。当他们到达那里时，他们驱逐了各种土著人民，与祖鲁人反复发生冲突，所有这些事情。所以对“大迁徙”的隐喻，我想对南非黑人来说是一个红旗。
Sud Africa, the call of South Africa. And just as white South Africans hate the ANC anthem, so black South Africans come to hate the apartheid anthem, I mean, entirely understandably. Now, in fact, like the lyrics from Cozy, those of De Stem are actually pretty mellow in tone. So there is one mention in it of the groan of the Oxwagon. And, And this is an allusion to the Vue Trekkers, the Boers who had sought to escape British rule in the 19th century. So migrating from the Cape Colony to the interior of South Africa. And when they get there, they kind of displace various native peoples, have repeated punch up with the Zulus, all this kind of thing. So the illusion to the Vour Trekkers is a kind of red flag, I guess, to black South Africans.
但除此之外，歌词中没有任何明显冒犯的内容。因为本质上，这是一首对南非美景的赞美诗，也感谢创造了这些美景的上帝。所以它的开篇是：从我们天空的蔚蓝，从我们海洋的深处，越过我们永恒的山脉，回荡着我们呼唤的悬崖。我的意思是，这些是南非每个人都能同意的情感。绝对，你知道，绝对是普世的基调。所以种族隔离政权在20世纪90年代初倒台了。
but otherwise there's nothing in the lyrics that would be obviously offensive. Because essentially it's a hymn of love to the beauties of South Africa and also thanks to God who had fashioned these beauties. So it's opening lines from the blues of our heavens, from the depths of our sea, over our everlasting mountains, where the cliffs echo back our calls. I mean, these are sentiments that everyone in South Africa could agree with. Absolutely, you know, absolutely ecumenical in tone. So the apartheid regime falls in the early 1990s.
显而易见的问题是，新南非采用什么国歌？多数人显然是黑人。你会认为他们会简单地扔掉《南非之声》，用《上帝保佑非洲》取而代之，这当然是一首我想大多数南非黑人都会支持的歌。但事情并非完全如此，不是吗？
And the obvious question is, what is the new South African who adopters this anthem? The majority is obviously black. You would assume they are simply going to throw out De Stem and to replace it with Enkosie, which is, of course, a song that the majority, I guess, of black South Africans would get behind. But that's not quite what happens, is it?
是的，1994年初，就在曼德拉作为南非第一位黑人总统就职之前。非国大的最高决策核心举行了一次会议，决定国歌将是什么。这很紧迫，因为来自世界各地的人们将参加曼德拉的就职典礼。所以他们确实需要一首国歌。正如你所说，绝对不可想象
Yeah, so early in 1994, just before Mandela's inauguration, as South Africa's first black president. The ANC kind of supreme decision-making caucus hold a meeting to decide what the anthem is going to be. And it's pressing because people from around the world are going to be coming for Mandela's inauguration. And so they do need an anthem. As you say, it's absolutely inconceivable
他们会保留《南非之声》。压倒性的共识是它应该是《上帝保佑非洲》。他们等曼德拉出去接电话，当他去接电话时，他们说，是的，我们要用《上帝保佑非洲》。曼德拉回来后，他们告诉他，这是我们的决定。他大发雷霆。他非常愤怒。
that they will have to stem. And the kind of the overwhelming consensus is that it should be cozy. And they wait for Mandela to pop up. out for a phone call and while he's gone to take the call, they say, yeah, we'll have in Cozy Sicolalia, Africa. Mandela comes back, they tell him, this is our decision. He blows a gasket. He is furious.
他告诉他们，这首歌，《南非之声》，你们处理得如此随意，承载着许多你们尚未代表的人的情感。只需笔尖一挥，你们就会做出决定去摧毁我们正在建立的唯一基础，即和解。所以曼德拉的解决方案，非常中间派，保留两首国歌。而且，为了保险起见，将《上帝保佑非洲》翻译成第二种南非语言，塞索托语。所以基本上，每个人都会高兴。我想，你知道，这算是面面俱到了。
He tells them, this song, De Stem, that you treat so easily, holds the emotions of many people who you don't represent yet. With the stroke of a pen, you would take a decision to destroy the very, the only basis that we are building upon, reconciliation. So Mandela's solution, very centrist, keep both anthems. And also, just for good measure, include a translation in Kosey into a second South African language, Sasotho. So basically, everyone will be happy. I think, you know, kind of ticking all the boxes there.
但这有一个问题。因为如果你把这三首歌一起播放，它持续了超过五分钟。我的意思是，它没完没了。在曼德拉的就职典礼上，其中一位嘉宾是菲利普亲王。菲利普亲王是一个人。是的，他有什么说什么。是的，他实话实说。他开玩笑说，为了表示对国歌的尊重，他不得不脱帽太久，以至于他中暑了。
But there is a problem with this. Because if you play all three songs together, it lasts for more than five minutes. I mean, it just goes on and on. And at Mandela's inauguration, one of the guests is Prince Philip. Prince Philip is a man. Yeah, he calls it as he sees it. Yeah, he calls it as it is. and he jokes that he'd had to keep his hat off for so long, you know, as a mark of respect for the anthem, that he'd got sunstroke.
甚至曼德拉本人也承认，到最后这确实有点无聊。所以这里显然有一个问题。于是，当面对一个无法解决的问题时，他想出了经典的政客诡计。他把它交给了一个委员会。我想你可以说他把它踢开了。那是一个橄榄球隐喻吗？是的。然后还有一个排球隐喻要跟进，不是吗？
And even Mandela himself acknowledges that it was all a bit boring by the end. So there's obviously an issue here. And so he comes up with the classic politician's wheeze when faced with an imponderable problem. He hands it over to a committee. I suppose you could say he kicks it into touch. Would that be a rugby kind of metaphor? Yeah. And then there's some line out metaphor to follow, no?
所以这个委员会在1995年初，即橄榄球世界杯那年开会。起初，委员会真的很挣扎，因为挑战实际上相当严重。因为曼德拉授权他们实现两个看似矛盾的目标。所以第一个是确保国歌不会太长。你知道，他不希望未来的政要死于中暑。同时，它必须包含非国大的国歌和种族隔离政权的国歌。曼德拉的明确指示是，不要废除任何东西，要具有包容性。所以这是一个真正的问题。这有点像，是的，让它长一点，但要剪掉它。
So this committee meets early in 1995, the year of the Rugby World Cup. And to begin with, the committee are really struggling because the challenge is actually quite a serious one. Because Mandela has mandated them to meet two seemingly contradictory objectives. So the first one is to ensure the anthem isn't too long. You know, he doesn't want dignitaries dying of heat stroke in the future. Simultaneously, it has to incorporate both the A and C anthem and the Apartout. regime anthem. And Mandela's precise instructions are, don't scrap anything, be inclusive. So that's a real problem. It's kind of, yeah, make it a bit longer, but cut it.
还有，是的，在两分钟左右的时间里完成所有这些。是的。当然，橄榄球世界杯就要来了。决赛将于5月25日举行。很明显，国歌在那之前不会准备好。这意味着这两首国歌《上帝保佑非洲》和《南非之声》都必须在世界杯决赛中演唱，这反过来意味着这对跳羚队来说将是一个巨大的考验，正如我们所说。你知道，他们必须在世界媒体摄像机的全方位注视下演唱它。对于埃利斯公园球场（Ellis Park Stadium）的观众来说，你知道，观众会对这首70年来一直是非国大国歌的歌曲作何反应？答案是他们的反应非常好。
Also, yeah, do all that in two minutes or whatever. Yeah. And of course, you've got the Rugby World Cup coming along. It's going to be held, the final is going to be held on the 25th of May. It's obvious that the anthem is not going to be ready in time for that. And that means that These two anthems in Cozy, Sicoleli, Africa and De Stem, are both going to have to be sung at the World Cup final, which in turn means it is going to be a massive test for the Springboks, as we've said. You know, they've got to sing it in full view of the cameras of the world's media. And for the crowd in Ellis Park Stadium, you know, how is the crowd going to respond to what for 70 years has been the ANC anthem? And the answer is that they respond amazingly well.
所以跳羚队，他们表现出色。原因在于，在决赛前一个月，他们都接受了如何演唱非国大国歌的课程。幸运的是，其中两个是在东开普长大的农场男孩，他们已经会说科萨语了。所以那很好。其他人，你知道，他们根本不知道，但他们非常乐意投入学习。在决赛中，你知道，他们在比赛开始前排在球场上。他们所有人，至少都在假装动嘴唱词。
So the spring box, they excelled themselves. And the reason for this is that a month before the final, they'd all been given lessons in how to sing the ANC anthem. Fortunately, two of them who were farm boys raised in the Eastern Cape, they already spoke Losa. So that was good. The others, you know, they had no idea, but they throw themselves very gainly into learning it. And at the final, you know, they're lined up on the pitch before the start of the match. and all of them, at the very least, are kind of pretending to mouth the words.
看起来他们不是完全不知道。看起来他们确实知道歌词是什么。事实上，如果你看录像，唯一一个没有唱的人是队长弗朗索瓦·皮纳尔（François Pienaar）。他事后说，我无法唱这首国歌，我不敢，因为我知道如果我唱了，我会崩溃的。
It doesn't look like they've got no idea. It does look like they know what the words of the song are. And actually, the only one who doesn't sing, if you look at the footage of it, the only one who doesn't is the captain, François Pinaar. And the reason for this, he said afterwards, I couldn't sing the anthem, I dared not, because I knew that if I did, I'd fall about.
哦，他是个软心肠。是的。在扮演敌人时，约翰·卡尔（John Carlin）在《成事在人》（Invictus）中，全黑队队长肖恩·菲茨帕特里克（Sean Fitzpatrick）后来告诉皮纳尔，他告诉我他看过去，看到一滴眼泪顺着我的脸颊流下。所以这是一个极其感人的时刻，观众也对此表示尊重。你知道，他们的表现真的非常好。在这个场合的神话中，它被塑造成激发了整个彩虹国家、彩虹民族概念的东西。我认为对这一点持怀疑态度、持愤世嫉俗的态度很容易。
Oh, he's a softy out. Yeah. And in playing the enemy, John Carl, in Simon, what Sean Fitzpatrick, who was the all black captain, later told Pinar, so he told me that he looked over and saw a tear rolled down my cheek. So an incredibly emotional moment, and it is respected as such by the crowd. You know, they really behave very well. And in the mythology of this occasion, it's kind of cast as something that inspires the entire notion of a rainbow country, a rainbow nation. And I think it's kind of easy to be skeptical about that, to be cynical.
但我认为相反的情况显然是真的，跳羚队未能演唱非国大国歌，也就是现在的南非国歌，我认为那会对“一个团队，一个国家”的任何概念，任何前景造成毁灭性的打击……好吧，想象一下如果观众嘘它。我的意思是，那里的观众非常白人。想象一下如果白人观众嘘国歌。我的意思是，再没有比这更具腐蚀性的了。是的。所以我认为他们没有那样做，而且表现得很好，这真的很重要。
But the converse, I think, is clearly true that the spectacle of the Springboks failing to sing the A&C anthem, what is now the South African anthem, I think that would have dealt a really devastating blow to kind of any notion of one team, one country, any prospect of... Well, imagine if the crowd had booed it. I mean, that crowd is very white. Imagine if the white crowd had booed the anthem. I mean, that would have nothing more corrosive could be imagined. Yeah. And so I think it really, really mattered that they didn't do that and that they behaved themselves.
在比赛结束时，皮纳尔，你知道，他在整个锦标赛中表现出色。他给出了绝对完美的金句。所以一位体育记者问他，有62,000名球迷在这里支持你，感觉如何？皮纳尔的回答让曼德拉感到骄傲。我们身后没有62,000名球迷，我们有4300万南非人。所以全场无不落泪。
And at the end of the match, Pinaar, who is, you know, he's played a blinder throughout the tournament. He serves up the absolutely perfect soundbite. So a sports reporter asks him, how did it feel to have 62,000 fans supporting you here in the stadium? And Pina's answer does Mandela proud. We didn't have 62,000 fans. behind us, we had 43 million South Africans. So not a dry eye in the house.
但他们唱了两首国歌。他们此时实际上并没有一首国歌。所以委员会直到世界杯，橄榄球世界杯两年后才拿出报告。他们的解决方案，我的意思是，这是一个权宜之计吗？我想这确实是一个权宜之计，不是吗？好吧，如果你认为披头士乐队伟大的歌曲《A Day in the Life》，将约翰·列侬和保罗·麦卡特尼的两首独立歌曲融合在一起，被视为《佩珀军士》专辑中的杰作，那是一个权宜之计，那么这就是。我不认为这是一个权宜之计。
But they've sung both anthems. They actually don't have one anthem at this point. So the committee doesn't come up with its report until two years after the World Cup, after the Rugby World Cup. And their solution, I mean, is it a fudge? I guess it is a fudge, really, isn't it? Well, it's a fudge if you think that a day in the life, the Beatles great song, which fuses two separate songs by John Lennon and Paul McCartney into what is often seen as the masterpiece on Sergeant Pepper, whether that's a fudge. I don't think it's a fudge.
我认为他们做了完全一样的事情。他们将《上帝保佑非洲》和《南非之声》融合成一首歌，它在音乐上行得通，但在意识形态上也行得通，因为实际上当你把这两首歌的歌词配对时，你会意识到它们都源于一种共同的基督教非洲文化，因为两首歌都在表达一个相同的信念，即上帝对南非给予了特殊的祝福，而生活在
I think they do exactly the same. They fuse Enkose Sicoleli Africa and De Stem into a single song, and it works musically, but it also works ideologically as well, because actually when you pair the lyrics from the two songs, you realize that both of them have emerged from, a common Christian African culture because both songs are expressing an identical conviction, namely that God has bestowed particular blessings on South Africa and that people who live in
南非的人们，因此，应该对这些祝福心存感激。所以实际上，它们融合得非常完美。然而，委员会真的咬定牙关，因为他们觉得仅仅把这两首歌放在一起实际上是不够的，我们最好也加入一大堆其他东西，你知道，因为南非有各种各样不同民族的语言。所以他们将新国歌翻译成不少于南非11种官方语言中的5种。所以其中一种显然是科萨语，即《上帝保佑非洲》的前两行，正如桑通加所写的那样。然后是祖鲁语。所以原曲的第三和第四行被翻译成那种语言。
South Africa, therefore, should be grateful for those blessings. So actually, they kind of, they blend perfectly. However, the committee have really got the beat between their teeth because they feel that it's actually not enough just to have these two songs put together. we better chuck in a whole load of other stuff as well, you know, because there are loads and loads of languages of different kind of peoples in South Africa. So they render the new anthem into no less than five of South Africa's 11 official languages. So one of them is obviously Osa, the first two lines of Kosea Sicolalei Africa, as Sontanga had written them. Then you have Zulu. So the third and fourth lines of the original are translated into that.
然后是塞索托语，这是一节请求上帝保护南非的诗句。然后是《南非之声》，那是南非荷兰语。最后一节是用英语写的，专门为新国歌创作。这非常平淡。呼吁团结一致，我们将站在一起。让我们在南非，我们的土地上，为自由而生活和奋斗。我的意思是，当他们在橄榄球比赛前演唱时，他们的声音在那一刻升起。我认为这是一个非常强大的高潮。
Then you have Sissotu, which is a verse asking God to protect South Africa. Then you have Dishem, so that's Afrikaans. And then the last verse is in English, composed specially for the new anthem. And this is very bland. Sounds the call to come together and united, we shall stand. Let us live and strive for freedom in South Africa, our land. I mean, when they're singing before a rugby match, their kind of voices arising at that point. It is a very powerful climax, I think.
是的，我的意思是，歌词可能不像早期的那样有力，但它们完成了它们必须做的事情。所以你在南非国歌中有这五种不同的语言。这使它非常、非常特别。事实上，只有一个国家有多种语言的国歌。这就是苏里南，
Yeah, I mean, the lyrics are not as powerful, perhaps, as the early ones, but they do what they've got to do. So you have these five different languages in the South African National Anthem. And that makes it very, very exceptional. And in fact, there is only one other country that has a multilingual anthem. And this is Surinam,
南美洲北海岸的一个国家。它最初是英国殖民地，回到17世纪。然后在1667年，它被荷兰人用新阿姆斯特丹（后来成为纽约）交换了。所以英国人得到了后来成为纽约的地方，荷兰人得到了苏里南，我认为基本上英国人在那笔交易中占了便宜。然而，话虽如此，我的意思是，英国人最终失去了纽约，当然，但荷兰人保留了苏里南近350年，苏里南直到1975年才获得最终的独立。但即使在那之前，它也采用了一首国歌，
so country on the north coast of South America. It had originally been an English colony, so back in the 17th century. then in 1667 it gets swapped by the Dutch for New Amsterdam, which becomes New York. So the English get what will become New York and the Dutch gets Suriname and I think basically the English have the better of that deal. However, having said that, I mean, the English end up losing New York, of course, but the Dutch keeps Surinam for almost 350 years and Suriname only obtained its kind of ultimate independence in 1975. but even before that it had adopted an anthem that
有两节，一节是荷兰语，一节是一种语言，我希望我发音正确，苏里南语（Sranan Tongo），这是一种英荷克里奥尔语，我的意思是，大概是苏里南语。是的，是的，所以我认为这是一种，它是奴隶们在那里说的语言。是的。可能有一种关于英荷殖民融合的东西，促进了多语言国歌，因为苏里南和南非的历史之间显然存在一种对应关系。我知道在你的笔记中你说，尽管苏里南国歌很好，但它真的无法与《上帝保佑非洲》相比。
had two verses, so one in Dutch and one in a language called I hope I'm pronouncing this right, Suran Tong which is an Anglo-Dutch Creole I mean sort of Surinam tongue presumably. Yes, yeah, so I think it's a kind of, it's the language that was spoken by the
它通过苏里南国歌告诉我。它有多好？它不是很好。它不是很好。好吧，它还可以，但我不认为它是一首热门歌曲。你真的听过吗？是的，我听过。
slaves there. Yeah. And it may be there's something about kind of Anglo-Dutch colonial fusion but fosters multilingual national anthems because there is clearly a kind of correspondence between the history of Surinam and South Africa. And I know in your notes you say that as fine as the Surinam National Anthem is, it can't really compose within Cozy, Sicily, Africa.
哦，做得好。因为我一直在想它是否会很好。是的。事实上，我的意思是，它还可以，但它真的没什么别的。好吧，我的意思是，它是两首多语言国歌之一。我认为这使它在人群中脱颖而出。我的意思是，我们在这个系列中只谈论了两个南美国家的国歌，巴西，现在是苏里南。是的，这对阿根廷来说是一个可怕的决定。
It's told me through the Surinam National Anthem. How fine is it? It's not very fine. It's not very fine. Well, it's all right, but I don't think it's a banger. Have you actually ever heard it? Yes, I have. I listened to it.
他们会气疯的。好吧。那么让我们回到南非国歌。你说它是20世纪国歌中最令人难忘和最具历史共鸣的。我想那是真的，不是吗？因为有，我们做过很多有很多历史的国歌，但没有哪一首的过去像这样充满了苦难和殉道。这是一段令人难忘的旋律。
Oh, well done. Because I was wondering if it was going to be any good. Yeah. And actually, I mean, it's all right, but it's literally nothing else. Well, I mean, it's one of two multilingual national anthems. I think that makes it stand out from the crowd. I mean, we've only talked about the anthems of two South American countries in this series, Brazil, and now at Suriname. Yeah, this is a terrible resolve for Argentina.
歌词显然令人难忘，即使我必须翻译它们。它缺乏那种往往是19世纪起源的大多数国歌特征的滚动铜管乐器的昂首阔步，我认为，它有一种非常、非常不同的品质。它几乎像是一首挽歌，不是吗？我总是这样想，它的声音。是的，它真的很强大。所以在那一点上，挽歌，
They'll be fuming. Right. So let's get back to the South African anthem. You say it's the most haunting and historically resonant of 20th century national anthems. And I guess that's true, isn't it? Because there are, we've done a lot of anthems with a lot of history. but none whose past is so kind of freighted with suffering and martyrdom and stuff. And it is a haunting melody.
让我们通过回到写这首歌的人埃里克·桑通加（Eric Sontonga）来结束这一集和这个系列。我们说过，在他被埋葬在约翰内斯堡布拉姆方丹墓地后，他墓地的所有痕迹都消失了。他是非国大神话中的著名人物，写了他们国歌的人。所以有很多尝试去识别它。没有人能找到它。但后来终于，在20世纪90年代初，你可以看出为什么这，你知道，曼德拉的释放刺激了一种重新尝试去追踪它的努力。一位研究人员有了一个灵感。为什么不在墓地记录中查找呢？不是找桑通加，而是找伊诺克，他的名字。
The words are obviously haunting, even though I have to have them translated. And it lacks the kind of rolling brass-based strut that tends to be a characteristic of most national anthems that have originated in the 19th century, I think, has a very, very different quality. It's almost like a lament, isn't it? I always think, the sound of it. Yeah, it's really powerful. And so on that note, the lament,
在那里，果然，他们找到了他，4800号墓。他的姓氏被完全抹去，取而代之的是侮辱性的南非荷兰语词汇，用来称呼黑人。结果他们能够算出墓地在哪里。1996年，即他的赞美诗在埃利斯公园球场演唱、被世界各地的人们听到一年后，埃利斯公园球场距离他被埋葬的墓地只有大约三英里。纳尔逊·曼德拉抵达那里，为桑通加的纪念碑揭幕，该纪念碑建在他墓地的遗址上。曼德拉说，带着我们无论顺境逆境都高声歌唱你的旋律和歌词的自豪感，
let's end this episode and the series by going back to Eric Sotonga, the man who wrote it. And we said that after his burial in the Bramfontein graveyard in Johannesburg, all the traces of his grave were lost. He's a famous figure in
我们是在对你说，伊诺克·曼凯·桑通加，有了你的灵感，我们可以移山。我想，从某种意义上说，他们做到了。哦，那是一个很好的结局。在“历史的其余部分”中有一个快乐的结局真是太好了。我们没有足够的快乐结局。所以这是一个了不起的故事，迷人的故事，讲述得非常精彩。谢谢你，汤姆。所以这是我们世界杯系列的结束。我认为这是一个比实际世界杯更好的系列。世界杯里有太多的球队，而我们限制了自己。
A&C mythology, the guy who wrote their anthem. And so there had been lots of attempts to try and identify it. And nobody could find it. But then finally, in the early 1990s, and you could see why this, you know, Mandela's release has stimulated a kind of renewed attempt to try and track it down. A researcher has the kind of brainwave. Why not look up in the cemetery records? Not for a Sontanga, but for an Enoch, his first name.
是的。我认为一个只有16支球队的世界杯会是，我的意思是，它会非常有冲击力，不是吗？它会很有冲击力，但它会是精英吗？我们追求的就是精英。精英内容。好吧，它实际上会像橄榄球一样。它会像，什么，六国赛？完全正确。是的，它会像六国赛。他们都互相比赛。
And there, sure enough, they find him, grave number 4,800. His surname had been completely erased and replaced by the insulting Afrikaans' word for a black person. And they were able, as a result of this, to work out where the grave was. And in 1996, so one year after his hymn had been sung at Ellis Park Stadium, heard by people around the world, Ellis Park Stadium was only about three miles away from the cemetery in which he'd been buried. Nelson Mandela arrived to unveil a memorial to Sontonga that had been raised on the site of his grave. And Mandela said this, By the pride with which we bellowed your melody and its lyrics in good times and bad,
果然，他们在那里找到了他，第4800号墓。他的姓氏被完全抹去，取而代之的是一个对黑人带有侮辱性的南非荷兰语词汇。正因如此，他们才得以确定墓地的位置。1996年，也就是他的赞美诗在埃利斯公园球场被唱响、被全世界人民听到的一年后，纳尔逊·曼德拉来到这里，为桑通加的墓地纪念碑揭幕，而埃利斯公园球场距离他安葬的墓地仅有三英里左右。曼德拉这样说道：正是因为我们怀着自豪，在顺境和逆境中高唱你的旋律和歌词，
we were saying to you, Enoch, Manjaic, we were saying to you, Enoch, Mankei, Sontonga, that with your inspiration, we could move mountains. And I guess, in a sense, they had. Oh, that's a nice ending. It's nice to have another happy ending on the rest of history. We don't have enough. So that's an amazing story, fascinating story, brilliantly told. Thank you, Tom. So that's the end of our World Cup series. I think a better series than the actual World Cup. They've got too many teams in the World Cup, whereas we limited ourselves.
我们是在对你说，伊诺克·曼凯·桑通加，有了你的激励，我们就能移山填海。我想，从某种意义上说，他们确实做到了。哦，这是一个美好的结局。在《历史的其余部分》中能有另一个圆满的结局真是太好了。我们这样的故事还不够多。这是一个了不起的故事，引人入胜，讲述得非常精彩。谢谢你，汤姆。这就是我们世界杯系列的终点。我认为这个系列比真正的世界杯还要精彩。世界杯的参赛队伍太多了，而我们限制了参赛数量。
Yeah. I think a World Cup with only 16th would be, I mean, it'd be very punchy, wouldn't it? It would be punchy, but it would be elite? And we're all about elite. Elite content. Well, it would be like the rugby, actually. It would be like the, what's it, the Six Nations? Exactly. Yeah, it would be like the Six Nations. They all play each other.
是的。我认为只有16支球队参加的世界杯会非常精彩，不是吗？会很精彩，但会是精英级别的吗？我们追求的就是精英。精英内容。嗯，这实际上会像橄榄球比赛一样。就像那个，六国锦标赛？没错。是的，就像六国锦标赛。他们每个人都互相比赛。
So talking of elite content, we are returning next week with an absolutely elite series because not only is this summer, the summer of the Football World Cup, it is the summer in which the tax revolt of 1776 will be 250 years old. God, so many back taxes to be paid. And the rebel state formed as a result of that event is marking its 250th anniversary. I think the world is looking at the United States of America and saying, how have things worked out for them? How are their politics looking now? Are they perhaps regretting?
说到精英内容，我们下周将回归，带来一个绝对精英的系列节目。因为今年夏天不仅是足球世界杯之夏，也是1776年税收起义250周年纪念之夏。天哪，还有这么多欠税要付。而作为那次事件结果而成立的叛乱国家，也正在纪念其250周年。我想世界正在审视美利坚合众国，并问道：他们的情况如何？他们现在的政治面貌如何？他们是否感到后悔？
Are they in danger of crawling back and asking to be readmitted? I mean, the problem with that diagnosis, Dominic. To the family of civilized nations. Well, yeah, I mean, that implies that Britain's been doing better. I'm not entirely sure that that's... On the other hand, of course, they could look north and say Canada is the country they could have been. Anyway, to mark this event, because we do like our American listeners, to reach out to them and to give them a little favor, we are going to be doing a series about the founding fathers.
他们是否有危险会爬回去请求重新加入？我的意思是，多米尼克，这种诊断的问题在于……回到文明国家大家庭。嗯，是的，我的意思是，那暗示着英国做得更好。我不确定那是否……另一方面，当然，他们可以向北看，说加拿大是他们本可以成为的国家。总之，为了纪念这一事件，因为我们确实喜欢我们的美国听众，为了接触他们并给他们一点优待，我们将制作一个关于开国元勋的系列节目。
Four of them. Yes. George Washington, Benjamin Franklin, Thomas Jefferson and Alexander Hamilton. And we shall, of course, be treating them, Tom, with the reverence and we. respect they deserve with exactly the amount of respects and reverence they deserve. So for our American listeners, it should be an eye-opening experience. Now, if our American listeners, I imagine even now, they're like, they're scrabbling desperately their keyboards to try to work out how they can get access to this series early to hear this patriotic fest. Because it'll really broaden their minds.
其中四位。是的。乔治·华盛顿、本杰明·富兰克林、托马斯·杰斐逊和亚历山大·汉密尔顿。当然，汤姆，我们将以他们应得的敬意和尊重来对待他们，以他们应得的恰当程度的尊重和敬意。所以对于我们的美国听众来说，这应该是一次大开眼界的经历。现在，如果我们的美国听众，我想即使是现在，他们也像是在拼命敲击键盘，试图找出如何能提前获得这个系列节目的访问权限，来收听这场爱国盛宴。因为它真的会拓宽他们的视野。
Tom, is there any way, is there any mechanism or process by which somebody could listen to all of that series on Monday if they wanted to. They absolutely could. They could sign up to The Rest Is History Club. You know, as we said, there's a lot of back tax to be paid. It's actually unbelievably good value. Just a very tiny minute number of your tax dollars could go on it. I mean, just insane value because you get a whole load of additional benefits as well.
汤姆，有没有什么方法或流程可以让某人在周一就听完整个系列节目？他们绝对可以。他们可以注册加入“历史余韵”俱乐部（The Rest Is History Club）。你知道，正如我们所说，有很多欠税要付。这实际上是非常超值的。只需花费你税金中极小的一部分。我的意思是，这简直是超值，因为你还能获得一大堆额外的好处。
I don't think we've ever mentioned that before. So very, very exciting. And of course, you don't have to be American to do that, either, do you? Because the founding fathers are remarkable characters. Their stories are remarkable. So of interest to one and all. So we hope you enjoy that series coming up starting next Monday. Brilliant. So we'll see you on next Monday for the founding fathers. But until then, Tom, thank you very much. That was a brilliant episode. Bye-bye, everybody. Bye-bye. 150 years ago, they were hunting us down to kill us,
我不认为我们之前提到过这一点。所以非常非常令人兴奋。当然，你不必是美国人也能这样做，对吧？因为开国元勋们是了不起的人物。他们的故事非常引人入胜。所以这对每个人都有吸引力。我们希望你们喜欢下周一开始的那个系列节目。太棒了。那么我们下周一见，聊聊开国元勋。但在此之前，汤姆，非常感谢你。那是一集精彩的节目。再见，大家。再见。150年前，他们追捕我们并试图杀死我们，
and now they're hunting down immigrants to deport them. This is First America, the true story of how the United States came to be, and how we got to this present moment. Listen to First America wherever you get your podcast. Hi, everybody. It's Dominic Sandbrook here. There are two weeks to go until the rest is history's inaugural festival at Hampton Court Palace. And frankly, I could not be more excited. There's going to be medieval combat.
而现在他们正在追捕移民并将他们驱逐出境。这就是《第一美国》，讲述美国是如何形成的，以及我们是如何走到今天这一刻的真实故事。无论你在哪里收听播客，都可以收听《第一美国》。大家好，我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。距离“历史余韵”在汉普顿宫举办的首届艺术节还有两周时间。坦率地说，我感到无比兴奋。届时将会有中世纪的战斗。
There are going to be all sorts of big-name historians. You can go to the palace. You can feast like Henry VIII on the very lawns where he walked. In the sunshine, I'll be talking to Tracy Bournemon about the Tudors. I'll be talking to Katia Hoyer about Vimar Germany. I'll be talking to Ian Hislop about the history of satire. So it's on two days. It's on Saturday, the 4th of July.
会有各种大牌历史学家。你可以去宫殿。你可以在亨利八世曾经走过的草坪上像他一样享用盛宴。在阳光下，我将与特蕾西·博内蒙谈论都铎王朝。我将与卡蒂亚·霍耶谈论魏玛德国。我将与伊恩·希斯洛普谈论讽刺的历史。所以活动为期两天。是在7月4日星期六，
and Sunday the 5th of July. The bad news is we have actually sold out the allocations that we were given by Hampton Court for both days. The good news, however, we have persuaded Hampton Court to let us have more people. So there will be a handful of extra tickets available
和7月5日星期日。坏消息是，我们实际上已经卖光了汉普顿宫为这两天分配给我们的门票。然而，好消息是，我们已经说服汉普顿宫让我们接待更多的人。所以会有少量的额外门票可供购买，
for both the Saturday and the Sunday. Now, we do expect all of those extra tickets to sell out really quickly, so please do not wait to get your hands on them. The tickets are exclusive for club members. It's one of the benefits of being a member of the Restis History Club. Frankly, if you're not a member
周六和周日都有。现在，我们预计所有这些额外门票会很快售罄，所以请不要等待，尽快抢购。这些门票是俱乐部会员专享的。这是成为“历史余韵”俱乐部会员的好处之一。坦率地说，如果你不是会员，
and you would like to go to the festival, the only way to do that is by joining the club. So you have to head to therestishistory.com to sign up, and then you go to the members area once you've signed up and you select a festival to get your tickets. We are really hoping to see as many of you there as possible in the sunshine
而你想参加这个艺术节，唯一的办法就是加入俱乐部。所以你必须前往therestishistory.com注册，注册后进入会员区，然后选择艺术节来获取你的门票。我们真的希望在阳光下的汉普顿宫见到尽可能多的你们，
at Hampton Court. Bye-bye. Hi, everybody. Dominic here from the Restis History. You knew who is. it was. So we have just recorded a brilliant episode of our new mini-series about the World Cup and Dictatorships with Paul Rouse of University College Dublin. We were just talking about Pele and Brazil and the dictatorship that ruled Brazil between 1964 and 1985. We had a lot of fun, and we thought you might like to hear a little clip from it to wet your appetite if you're not a member of the Restis History Club. So here it is. Enjoy. So I guess the question with Brazil,
再见。大家好，我是“历史余韵”的多米尼克。你们知道是谁。所以我们刚刚与都柏林大学学院的保罗·劳斯录制了一集关于世界杯和独裁统治的精彩新迷你剧。我们刚才在谈论贝利和巴西，以及1964年至1985年间统治巴西的独裁政权。我们玩得很开心，我们想如果你不是“历史余韵”俱乐部的会员，你可能想听听其中的一小段来解解馋。所以就在这里。享受吧。所以我猜关于巴西的问题，
in particular is, we think that Brazil is defined more than anything else by football. The football is absolutely central to Brazilian national identity. The classic thing that people think, when we were talking about this before we started recording, the football is an expression of the Brazilian national soul in some way that it isn't in other countries. How and when does this idea become popular?
特别是，我们认为巴西最显著的定义就是足球。足球在巴西的国家认同中占据绝对核心地位。人们在录音前谈论这个时想到的经典观点是，足球在某种程度上是巴西民族灵魂的表达，而这在其他国家是不存在的。这个想法是如何以及何时变得流行的？
So in a global sense, it really took hold from the 1950s, Emirates, Brazil's successes in the 58 and 62 World Cup. And then, of course, they did three in a row in 1970. Unfortunately, it wasn't possible to play a World Cup in 1966. That's poor from you, Paul. Why do you hate? I mean, as we always say, why do you hate Britain?
从全球意义上讲，它确实是从20世纪50年代开始扎根的，巴西在58年和62年世界杯上的成功。然后，当然，他们在1970年实现了三连冠。不幸的是，1966年没能举办世界杯。你表现得太差了，保罗。你为什么讨厌？我的意思是，正如我们常说的，你为什么讨厌英国？
So that was important. That was important in the winning of a World Cup. At the very moment when television pictures begin to flow around the world of sporting. So the late 50s sport on television was beginning to be broadcast by 1962. You had an international broadcast through Telstar through the satellite. But by 1970, you have the projection around the world. In color. In color.
所以这很重要。这在赢得世界杯方面很重要。就在电视画面开始在世界各地传播体育赛事的时候。所以50年代末，电视上的体育节目开始播出，到1962年，你通过Telstar卫星进行了国际广播。但到了1970年，你已经在世界各地进行了投影。彩色的。彩色的。
But most people still are black and white telly. So we have to be careful not to overstate that. But it is the projection of this Brazilian greatness. at the very moment that you get an explosion of interest in television. Thank you for listening. I hope you enjoyed it. If you want to hear more, of course, you could go to The Restis History.com. You can subscribe.
但大多数人仍然看的是黑白电视。所以我们必须小心，不要夸大这一点。但这是巴西伟大的投射，正值电视兴趣爆发的时刻。感谢收听。希望你喜欢。如果你想听更多，当然，你可以去TheRestIsHistory.com。你可以订阅。
You'll hear the rest of that series. And you'll get a wonderful range of supplementary benefits. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你将听到该系列的其余部分。你还将获得一系列极好的补充福利。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。